[Music]
everything's a job that turns out
absolutely everything I recently did
some teaching at Drexel University
teaching writing and the students were
terrific very engaged with the reading
very intelligent and insightful it turns
out that when you teach you have to
grade like hundreds of papers right did
I tell you that part no you-you-you have
to grade like so many papers you have to
read
I signed a paper each week for ten weeks
so it turns out I had you know over a
hundred of these things just to read
right and yeah I thought I was just
being the cool teach right where's my
heart inside a part which is gonna
recite poems man like good to me grades
like what do you mean computer program I
had to learn this whole computer program
uh-huh when did you do that I'm
technically still doing it you are have
to finish the grades uh-huh which um I
and I have to completely understand this
computer program rich which I'm I don't
and I think they've already graduated so
I need to get this done but I'm here
well you're a handwriting guy right like
you do all your writing and long in
longhand I do
I wrote probably 75% of the book by hand
that's amazing yeah I heard you say
something like you didn't even know what
you had or how many words you had
written or anything like that you hadn't
put the pieces together and realize that
you had much more of a book than you
originally thought because you've just
been taking notes the whole time and
jotting down your thoughts well I'm on
planes a lot for Esquire and other
magazines and newspapers I contribute to
and I'm on trains a lot what I I don't
go into the city all the time but when I
do from the Hudson Valley I take the
metro-north I'm in public libraries a
lot and I'm at bars a lot of yeah and I
bring along these just cheap paper
notebooks you get at Walgreens or
something or kind of staples and I write
just start writing almost like automatic
writing like let's just see where this
goes I'm just going to start and fill
some pages with ink uh-huh and obviously
the chief benefit of that I'm not on
Instagram I'm not on my phone I turn off
the phone I turn off the laptop and
essentially forced myself into a
monastic circle of focus
and what I found with this book is I
wrote a lot of it by hand and I ended up
with you know 80,000 words I didn't know
how much I'd written
I knew I'd filled a couple of notebooks
and my wife was terrified that I would
lose the notebooks but I had to start
over the perils of the analog lines yeah
and guess what I almost did these jumble
airports yeah I didn't tell her but I
mean disaster was averted but the the
sweat beads on my forehead my guy I was
in a steep state of panic and helpful
times but even then I would just say
okay I guess I'll write the Norway
section now why not I'm in the mood for
Norway
you know I'll write the Brock section
now oh oh and I did not really know how
the sections fit together until later
when I started to put them into the
laptop do you write in the moment of
experiencing it or how much objectivity
time and space do you need to put
between you and the experience before
you feel like you can you know that's
gonna call it and you know in the best
way possible
that's a good question and there
definitely see it needs to be some kind
of delay and some sort of lag deepens it
enriches your knowledge and you have to
lessen and almost lessen the energy a
little bit so that you can look at it
more clearly it's very rare that I write
about something right away I would like
on a lot of the trips through Mexico
with Rene Redzepi I would take a lot of
notes
just sit at the back of the van
essentially and capture what everyone
was saying for days on end and then come
home and sort of process it you don't
tape record though because you're caught
you have these long quotes you know that
you'll be over this recollection of
these conversations they're just they're
just written down yeah they're written
down at but in in notebooks I do
occasionally record but for the then I
mean I spent weeks with the Noma team
you can't record weeks and weeks you
just end up with endless files that you
can't do anything with so we had a
fact-checker on it tim Hodler so he got
back to everyone and in fact Rene raised
up his wife Nadine gave me an
interesting compliment she was like so
I'm I'm talking the fact-checker and
it's uncanny like you completely
recreated entire conversations we had
and I was like okay are they accurate
she's like they're precisely what we
said
okay whoo that's what I want no that's a
compliment
if I'm not unclear about something
adjusting included I only included the
passages that I was clear on you know
that that's what the conversation was
and the quotes were precise and every
right sometimes at the end of the day
because one's handwriting can be messy I
will type the notes into the laptop not
as a written document but just just so
that the quotes sure you have an
accurate yeah cuz like yeah two weeks
later it might just look like scrawls
but I find that there's more continuity
to writing by hand you know you sort of
snap out of this trance after four or
five hours you know like wow I filled a
lot of pages and there there seems to be
a different kind of flow from that well
you don't seem like someone who gets
easily blocked I mean you're incredibly
doesn't article sheer number of articles
that you've written is insane it is and
I know the huns that even aren't online
oh yeah there's an entire decade that's
not yeah an entire decade I wrote for
Details magazine that from an online
standpoint does not exist and frankly
that was the best work I did but you
can't I mean I have it in my garage in
boxes if anyone wants to see why didn't
it ever get his details folded and the
Conde Nast I believe shut down the site
and so there's simply no way to access
those stories I mean I did a Tom Cruise
cover story a Keanu Reeves cover story I
remember that that maybe not my finest
moment I all I remember about that is
something about books soup and like the
search for a sandwich search for salmon
yeah yeah we went to books ooh we talked
about Proust we talked about Updike I
know we went looking for this sandwich
in Santa Monica right Bay City say
cities it's got the lettuce the shredded
lettuce uh uh he like lurks around book
soup late at night right like he's a
frequent customer the guides a deep dude
and a deep reader did you see the thing
he said on Colbert the other day no
Colbert asked him something about he
said Keanu what is the meaning of life
and I'll paraphrase because I remember
exactly what he said but there was a
long pause and he said
all I know is that when you're gone the
people who love you will miss you and it
was like this mic drop
no man Oh deep pro fun daddy
all religions boiled down to that all
belief systems encapsulated in Keanu's
you know cone there
well his myth has never been you know
deeper or richer than it is now I feel
like I was maybe ahead of the curve
because my Keanu profile in details was
like 2007 2008 and I was sort of you
know arguing for the depth and
importance of Keanu Reeves as as icon at
a time when he was a little bit
marginalized he his star had dimmed a
bit huh and I was like let's reconsider
Keanu poet philosopher um and not in a
joking way I mean he is incredibly
literate and thoughtful when you know
him and and and and sensitive he's a
really cool guy but anyway you can't
read that right now I mean if if your
listeners want to read I could find a
way to post it you should yeah I mean do
you own those stories now that it's
defunct you could take know that have
somebody typed them up and put them on
medium or something yeah fun I mean they
result there was a piece about the wedge
crew which was a it still is a gang of
sort of rogue body surfers down in
Orange County they surf a wave called
the wedge yeah famous wave
yeah destructive crashes right on top of
you yeah they don't eat their body
surfers you know you can't even have
surfboards in there cuz they'll impale
people I wrote about them I got them to
talk they were like Fight Club they
wouldn't talk and I have roots in that
part of the California and I got him to
talk and actually some friends of mine
from high school were in the wedge crew
I wrote about a mafia lawyer I wrote
about a contortionist I wrote about a
guy who repaired broken sex dolls uh-huh
sex dolls get to get broke and Weavin we
don't want to get into that you're onto
that story you know a lot of it is
desperation you know your editor will
come around like come on what do you got
cooking what's next and you're like
I don't know I don't know you're not in
and so you start googling madly talking
to people I think I got Nick I do
remember this I did some sort of event a
reading or something in Nevada
of course and it would have to be Nevada
or Florida Florida yeah it's like a
classic Florida man story and I and and
somebody said to me how do you come up
with articles how do you come up with
story ideas and I said you know it's
just it's in I believe in the universe
it stems to be signals like I'm a
California I believe this I talk like
this and she's she said if I come up
with a story idea for you on the spot
like you know you can owe me dinner or
something like that when I come to New
York or I was like okay nobody ever wins
at this but let's give it a go she's
like I know a guy in Northern California
who's the only person in America who can
repair broken sex dolls and I was like
where do you want to go to dinner this
table that's an amazing story
is this a real individual she's like
yeah his name's Slade Fiero of course
slave or sent to Fiero
and guess what he had been in up like a
parachuting what do they call when you
jump out of planes with a parachute
parachuting air dropping whatever it is
when people do that guy dies guy diving
thank you he had been in an accident
with that and and had really hurt his
spine and so he walked in this kind of
serpentine contorted way he was fairly
you know severely disabled from this
accident uh-huh and so there was this
interesting poetic connection actually
between the work he did on the dolls and
his own body having been hurt from this
this crash
so as often happened with my stories at
details and elsewhere it started as a
lark it's just like guy who repairs sex
dolls and I actually ended up becoming a
deeper piece about the human body and
about the way this gentleman would work
with these dolls you know in an almost
cathartic or therapeutic way regarding
himself
believe it or not he was a pretty deep
dude yeah cuz it sounds like a character
from a David Fincher movie so adventure
or David Lynch yeah
one of the David's one of the weird
David yeah but those were those were
good times and none of those you know
you can't find those stories online so
what about what was Cruz like oh wow
Tom Cruise was like this I'm looking
right like he doesn't blink he's like
looking right at you and so I did a
piece pegged to the Last Samurai which
is one of his movies and you know it it
was all he wanted to do something
connected to Japanese culture and so we
went to Euro Sawa era Sawa is like you
know one of the really rice super
high-end omakase places yeah and that
the fact is the hope it was in some ways
one of my first pieces of food writing
because the whole piece was about the
meal at this restaurant and how Tom
didn't actually eat it so he kept
talking about he's in smitten with
Japanese culture is obsessed he had
these books he'd brought a backpack full
of books of samurai quotes and haikus
and Buddhist wisdom and all this stuff
which I'm all about I was into that but
you know I was like you know on the
other hand Japanese culture he's right
here in front of us being presented by
these this is part of that it's right
here and and in a Japanese culture is
sort of lined up on the runway like
planes at LaGuardia being waiting to get
eaten here so uh and he was like oh no
I'm you know I'm not that hungry and
it's like okay well I'm eating it so I
hate to omakase meals cuz I like there
was this Chawan mushi which is kind of
like you know a custard and it had
flakes of edible gold on top Wow
and I kept going like Tommy you're gonna
eat that you're gonna eat the custard
yeah you can eat your pudding yes and he
finally he finally in one big slurp you
know took a spoon and just slurp down
the Chawan mushi and the goal uh-huh the
end was him eating gold Wow Oh
everything I've heard about that guy is
that he's just he's everything that you
want him to be he's hyper presence he's
completely focused on the person that
he's talking to yeah in a way that's you
know that that sort of transcends being
a human being
like in an alien sort of fashion yeah
you you're you're wondering like does he
break can he be broken can hi can I
knock him off track here he's definitely
not aging he's not aging he's he is not
just mentally focused on the
conversation but physically focused
there is a sense of like he he would
grab me on the shoulder to make a point
and squeeze hard you know even hurt
right
like he's strong and I'd be like let go
don't let go of my shoulder it was a
meme that went around the internet
recently
it was a picture of Wilford Brimley from
cocoon we've we've went from Tom Cruise
to Wilford yeah the joke was this is
this picture of Wilford Brimley he's the
same age as Tom Cruise's now oh wow yeah
that's heavy I know right
well you guys are aging backwards here
you know you're like Benjamin Button
we're just so we're fighting gravity
here we're doing the most ya can which
kind of brings us to how we met I mean
we met a couple years ago you came here
to interview us for a piece that you
were writing for the New York Times you
were exploring veganism and I remember
being kind of equal parts delighted by
you and also a little bit trepidatious
like like okay this right this guy's not
like some bloggers like this is the New
York Times like this could go either way
like I had this terror that you were
gonna write this piece that was gonna be
you know snark filled and and kind of
you know use us as comedic fodder for
very very easy to do that and I I don't
tend to I don't can't think of many
examples in my career where I've decided
to take that route I don't think it's
fair to people I have this terrible
blind spot as a journalist that I see
human beings as human beings uh-huh sue
me but I you know and I enjoyed talking
you guys with you know you've thought it
through you had an intelligent viewpoint
and frankly you know that I love writing
about veganism and I love writing about
the people who are passionate about it
and I think the movement behind it and
the growth of it over the last 10 20
years is
intoxicating and exhilarating to see I
don't like to write about that's a
system of eating or looking at the world
like that in an in a snarky way I don't
think that's fair to people particularly
in they're giving you their time also
maybe your listeners don't know that I
live here now as soon as I came to the
house I loved it so much they never so
been here ever since
yeah I've lived here for years finally
let you out rich it rich adopted me so
that shows you how much I like these
people no I mean it was it was a
beautiful experience you know you have
to really ask yourself some hard
questions when especially these days
with social media about how far you want
to go with mockery I mean I I honestly
think the politicians are fair game but
beyond that how much you want to
contribute toxics
you know toxicity to the world and and
negativity I I
criticism is one thing but just sort of
like there's a way in which snarkiness
tips very quickly into bullying like a
kind of yeah form of bullying but do you
feel how all journalists hate me for
saying that yeah but I mean there's a
there's a there's a sort of built-in
pressure into the you know clickbait
nature and and the manner in which
business is done in terms of online
journalism that I would imagine you know
puts pressure on journalists to come up
with a hot take or the crazy headline to
clickbait headline and you know snark
works
it gets clicks yeah gets eyeballs to get
you followers on is that part of the
conversation when you're you know
sitting with the editors that you work
with or how does that work in your own
no I've been blessed with some really
wonderful editors who are basically like
do your thing
write the pieces that reflect what you
believe is happening in the culture
whether it's the food culture that I
cover now or music or film right III
don't get pressure to crank out hot
takes no yeah yeah I did do a hot take
that went live today
yeah is it okay that I'm it is about
Bharata which is like I saw that like
[ __ ] you and your Bharata
you know do you come up with the titles
- oh I didn't really I might have just
said that informally and it ended up
being the the headline but um I don't
write the headlines they had an extra
page in the summer issue this is
essentially what happened they had an
extra page and they're like there's
something you wanted just riff on and I
was I travel around the country all year
going to restaurants huh all over the
country in in the world and in partner
that's research for our best bars issue
right package that came out this summer
and the best new restaurants that comes
out the end of the year it's a lot of
eating its kind of punitive amount of
eating it's it's not a healthy
enterprise let me tell you rich but um
you get weary of things you see on every
menu you're in Minneapolis you're in
Dallas you're in San Francisco you're in
Atlanta and you see burrata everywhere
and you just start to loathe the cliche
of that burrata itself whether it's a
dairy version or a non-dairy version is
a delicious thing ok I'm not opposed to
the deliciousness
it's just like if you saw bands using
the same chords over and over or using
the same drum sound right which happened
a lot in the 80s or you you have authors
mimicking each other or using a certain
voice in their writing that strikes you
as shots are tired and derivative yeah I
just don't like why is burrata on this
menu it's there for a simple reason
people order it they pay for it
you know it'll sell and there's nothing
wrong with that I just thought I'm a
little weary of it but you know dude
people hate the hate like the hate feeds
the hate I made the mistake of going on
Facebook just moments before parked here
and all these people are like will [ __ ]
in hahaha oh my god so maybe I was like
oh no what did I do
like am I just like pouring toxins into
the water supply here maybe I should
have just left burrata alone I didn't
even name any chefs I mean so it's not
like I'm attacking anybody by name but
um part of that is driven by the the
title of the piece like when you read it
it's not exactly as snarky as the title
would imply and right what you see in
magazine publishing more increasingly is
the difference between
the title of the piece in the online
version versus the title and print
because in print you don't need to grab
people in the same way yeah this is a
good question because a very perceptive
from a media standpoint like I did a
piece on this chef Frances momen who's
down in Argentina
well he's travelling all over the world
but he I interviewed him in on this
island in Patagonia and in print the
headline was some Led Zeppelin like you
know old kind of old-school Esquire
thing like in the Land of Fire and Ice
yeah yeah you almost imagine that Led
Zeppelin song with like yeah like
Valhalla and then in print it was says
like is Francis moment the most
interesting chef in the world right okay
I didn't write that I don't even really
agree with it it's meant to be I suspect
a nod toward that dough sekiz ad were
the most interesting man in the world
and so there's an element of satire to
it but the that that headline alone
brought so much spite upon the piece
like in the the the way that you take a
stance like that it draws eyeballs but
it also draws ire I here yes well done
so I understand it from an SEO
standpoint and everything I understand
they don't want these stories to vanish
and if they put something too nuanced as
the headline people just keep clicking
write it yes but people would probably
know Francis moment from chef's table
that's right an amazing episode on him
he's he's one of the most influential
chefs on Julie and he was kind of the
original core impetus to us doing these
retreats and the Italian cookbook that
that that Julie put to go no way because
not so much the fire part of what he
does but more the kind of traveling
gypsy you know travel the world and take
your crew with you and set up shop and
have an experience that brings your
expertise to a different region and
welcomes the expertise of that region
into it and that was really the spirit
like we wanted to take what we do and go
to different places
the world and collaborate with the local
chefs there and we've kind of done that
in Italy and a book came out of that
right the idea it was broader though
we're gonna go to all these places but
we're so we just keepin it right back to
Italy yeah but she she just absolutely
loves moment that's amazing I didn't
know that yeah I did not that's that's
you know momins next book is apparently
a vegetable cookbook I was it
he's obviously intensely associated with
meat yeah he himself seems to be moving
away from that right I'm interesting
it's really interesting considering his
philosophy Jeff the world is moving away
from me well I I suspect that is tria I
suspect that actually gonna have to I
mean at the chef's table I was
associated with and the thing I'm sort
of the only thing I'm recognized on the
street for now and then is is the
jeong-hwan episode a chef's table that I
appear in although I look much better
with the lighting they huh so sometimes
people are like are you the drunk guy or
did you just get really old and fat I'm
like no I'm him I'm just don't actually
look that good well a couple at first of
all put that aside I remember when you
came to our house to spend time with us
for that New York Times piece you had
just returned from South Korea having
that experience with her and you were
telling us about it and neither of us
had heard of her I didn't know anything
about her and you were just going on and
on about what an extraordinary
incredible experience this was and then
a couple weeks after the piece that you
wrote about us and kind of veganism
the piece that you wrote for on zhang
quan about about that experience was in
t-- magazine that's right
it's one of the most beautiful things
I've ever read and the photographs were
just exquisite I mean that that must
have I mean yes being in chef's table
but that article was really something
wrong well that article is why the
chef's table happened right I David
Gelber would admit that I mean a lot of
Western readers and viewers were not
familiar with John Colonna till that
piece so right explain her four people
are she is a buddhist nun at a monastery
in south korea
she's not a formally trained chef she
doesn't have a restaurant so she's the
only person who's appeared in chef's
table with that kind of background
her ethos is temple cuisine which is a
form of cooking that's been around for
centuries and it's associated with
Buddhist temples throughout Asia not
just Korea there's different
manifestations of it throughout Asia and
it's a vegan cuisine and everything is
everything that's used is from the
surrounding landscape with the exception
of the rice I mean they they bought the
rice but mushrooms herbs leaves
vegetables fruits all these things that
are plucked at the moment of freshness I
mean literally we were in the garden and
she's plucking things that she brings up
at the kitchen and starts cooking
moments later maybe she slurps in raw
maybe she cooks them in these bamboo
tubes and then other things are vegan
and on our products of nature but our
products of time so there are there are
things that are extremely fresh of the
moment and other things that are like a
soy sauce or gochujang like or a bean
paste donjon that if that could be 10
years old 30 years old even a hundred
years old they're they're you know the
people in the monastery are sort of
custodians of these sauces for
generations and they have such depth of
flavor and stuff into me obviously
everyone should know by now that vegan
cooking can be incredibly delicious and
creative I mean that's a given now we
know all about cashew butters and all
the different ways you can use different
fats and but these aged sauces in Korea
up the ante I mean there's nothing more
flavorful flavorful than that there's
nothing richer in a way than some of
these sauces and she just kind of
brushed a grilled vegetable with this a
mushroom wrap it in a leaf and brush it
with one of these sauces and your eyes
would roll back in your head it was like
most delicious thing Eric repair from
the Bernadin he and I went together and
at the end of a few days we will have
never felt better in my life right you
know so but just also on top of that the
incredible kind of patience and
mindfulness and artistry and care
that this woman like puts into every
meal that she makes like every every
everything that she does there's like
this intention behind it absolutely is
sort of brought forth in the flavor and
the presentation of her food people talk
about such-and-such chef putting love
into the food and it's kind of a cliche
in the food world but she does
intentionally pour love and bodhichitta
like good vibes and and good intentions
into into each dish into each ingredient
with prayers I mean she actually prays
over the food and she thinks about who's
going to be eating it and she she offers
it up as a gift to them and a way of
communicating it's very moving yeah and
it does make you wonder you know if it
has an effect not just on the
deliciousness but how you feel and we
were also I mean I've actually spent a
lot of time with the Dharma I spent many
years in meditation and studying the
Dharma and stuff so I have some
background in it and always find myself
drawn back to it similar to with
vegetarian or vegan eating it's it's
funny I think if some day comes and I'm
not just saying this to but to flatter
you are using me an audience just trying
to win fans on the show I've said this
to many people that like if the time
comes when I'm no longer officially
working as a food writer and having to
eat everything I have to eat everything
for me you've got you go to these
restaurants you order everything I
haven't yeah um
I sort of nibbled it and sip it I can't
possibly drink all the drinks I post on
Instagram I would be in deep trouble but
I would love to go vegan and and give it
a go I really would because I have had
weeks at a time when I did and I feel
extraordinarily better and so I think
when you were doing that story on us and
the kind of movement the vegan movement
that you that you didn't write about it
but that you actually were you did go
vegan for that period of time yeah I did
for another story involving Kathy
frostin and oh and Dan and yeah and and
well now that that's actually different
when the Dan Buettner when I did an
earlier one about veganism gaining in
popularity at restaurants and even
restaurants that serve meat and stuff
would have vegan
options in Los Angeles because so many
customers expected it right and tal
Ronin at crossroads of course I
interviewed and so I decided it's only
right to to to go vegan for a week go
fully plant-based I mean at least from
that within that framework of a week or
ten days it's kind of undeniable that
you feel better yeah I don't know if
that's true after months I've never gone
that low huh
I'm at 12 years I still feel okay yeah
yeah and you and you look 22 so not
quite I could run the beard out it's
pretty white the beard I'd keep growing
my my whiskers out it's not even a beard
and you're like oh I'm Santa Claus
right well you you're we're like the
same age you grew up in San Marino right
yeah I try to hide you go to high school
San Marino Heights did you yeah what you
know is like a team were you yeah man we
could have swum was did we talked about
this we did briefly but I know you like
were they in the Olympics or something
nah I know I wasn't that good did you
know Kirk Roche very well you're kidding
me did we talk about this a little bit
he went to Stanford right yeah he's one
of my best friends from yeah he was on
my team he had the same Reno High School
is one of the great swim right dynasties
in California you know it's funny cuz I
live in New York that means nothing to
anyone right sorry I'm bumping the mic
I'm getting so excited but uh you know
no one ever asked me about swimming
that's like I you know it I describe to
people it's like playing tax being in
Texas and playing football like it was a
huge deal yeah I sold to be on the swim
team in the water polo team right and
you know Mission Viejo everybody thinks
about but Sam Reno is a powerhouse that
was we had Bert Cantor and Tom Schmidt
as our coaches Tom Schmidt was who he
was nuts
he was intense we used to have these
board drills do you ever do that to you
water polo - no I never plan I like mice
coast
I'm from ocean sea so I didn't grow up
in a swimming mica my accent is good in
Californian as I talk about this but
like we on water polo in water polo
season which was Tom Schmidt at San
Marino if you made a mistake in practice
you had to do a board drill which meant
you had to climb up to the top highest
diving board you know of course in your
speedo it's totally huh humiliating in
another
self and and jump off
well everybody on a team threw water
pull the ball at you uh just abused
disliked yeah just getting pegged on the
way down yeah one get Jason Rothbart
broke his nose one time like it was
brutal you know so I and I made mistakes
wasn't that coordinated so I mean at one
point would swing I don't know why would
it happen with you but with your
swimming now I swam at Princeton too
are you dead yeah for Rob yeah for Rob
or who's I've thought about going there
I almost like I like Rob a lot yeah a
great guy yeah one day I went into Rob
and of course I trudged through the snow
to Jadwin gym or wherever whatever the
gym was where a pool was and I for some
reason I was being stridently California
and I refused to wear snow boots I was
wearing like vans in the snow you know
and I'm freezing it's 5:30 in the
morning you know morning workout right
get there smell the chlorine and
something clicked and I was like Rob Jon
now yeah he's like what you don't feel
good I was like I can't do this anymore
I've been doing this since I was 7 years
old
the chlorine I can't take it I can't go
back and forth in this pool anymore I'm
losing my mind I've never had a beer
this is crazy I'm in college I've never
partied I mean I'm not I just weird what
is my life he's like okay relax we're
like I wasn't that important to the team
so this was not an emergency I was like
the third sprinter you know it was I was
not a crucial cog on the team but he's a
good guy he was like just relax it'll be
but I never went back
actually I never went back I couldn't do
it anymore
I did start running and stuff but I
recently tried to swim in a pool in a
hotel in Detroit
ah-ha when I was there to check out
restaurants whoo yeah it was painful
that was not good 16 ladders I've wanted
to conk out so you were in then you
would know Dan Veatch and Jim talk ler
Veatch was on my team at Princeton yeah
yeah Beach I remember vividly my grass
with those guys I've known those guys my
whole life yeah features a class act
great car I'm still in touch with him I
talk to him all the time yeah I couldn't
talk to him because he was lapping me
the time he was walking so quickly he's
a he's a brilliant talent he went to the
Olympics
yeah he's incredible and when we were
kids it's some early swim meets he was
the guy who had age all of you know 15
or 14 or whatever would be going up to
every you know where the parents are the
timers and it's like summer league or
whatever introducing himself to every
parent shaking their hand like oh wow
this guy is gonna be President
yeah you could tell then like he's a big
banker now in San Francisco is that what
he does and Jim talk ler lives in
Chicago and still does masters and like
breaks all these masters world he still
looks like he like looks like he's 21
you know who really wants me start
swimming again who's that my wife yeah
she's like she's like I'm just putting
it out there I really like a swimmer's
body I mean to me that's the idea I was
like as opposed to a food writers body
you're saying you know like what's the
difference I keep these things in
balance that way balance one of these
days I'm gonna get two bouts there's a
scene in in hungry my book that's about
the workout that Rene Redzepi does
everyone I read about that it's pretty
intense
it was awful I look I'm so out of shape
now and I barely do anything I just walk
really if if even that and it involves a
lot of burpees and it's kind of like his
cooking is New Nordic like it's it's
like radical naturalism and his workout
is radical naturally on to it's almost
primitive its right it's like just run
back and forth really quickly now
scuttle around like a crab now climb up
this tree now try to slap the other
guy's knee and if you if he slaps your
knee first you have to do ten burpees I
mean I do one Burpee and I thought I was
having a stroke so it was really hard
yeah there's a parallel between his
hyper local cuisine and his interest in
sustainability and all of these things
with his he's not going to a gym or you
know putting on a GPS watch like he's
using what he finds in his backyard yeah
I mean I would travel through Mexico
with them and him and Thomas were able
in particular one of the members of his
team is in wicked shape and everything
like they would just put a rope over a
tree branch and start like doing
pull-ups on it uh-huh
they would just do that right for the
hell of it I was like I will never do
that you ever heard of the have you ever
heard of the happy pair here's a story
for you yeah
you know these guys uh I could pretend
they're twins there are these twins
they're identical twins they're like the
most identical of identical twins they
look dna-tested like almost identically
the same person yeah basically they are
they finish each other's sentences
literally and they live in Graystone's
Ireland which is like an hour south of
Dublin Oh and they started this veg shop
that became a plant-based cafe and now
they're really the face of kind of
healthy living and eating in Ireland and
it's quickly kind of spreading out
across the world they were kind of
adopted by Jamie Oliver and you know he
he sort of introduced them to the world
through his youtube channel now they
have their they have like three or four
cookbooks they're all number one
bestsellers in the UK and they've got
YouTube and all this kind I've had him
on the podcast a bunch and yeah I
visited them in Graystone's a couple
times and they kind of visit us on our
retreats in Italy we were just with them
a couple weeks ago and they've created
this movement where now people migrate
to this little village in Ireland and
Graystone's
to just catch a glimpse of them and eat
a meal at their cafe and they do this
thing every morning called swim rise or
at the crack of [ __ ] you know it
whenever the Sun comes up we can swear
the Sun comes up they they go jump in
the Irish Sea 365 degree days a year
every day January February whenever and
it started with just them and a couple
other friends and now literally hundreds
of people show up every morning and they
drive or they fly to just have this
experience with them and it's pretty
cool what they've created like they
really have created this movement that's
very populist and inclusive around
healthy eating and living and they also
work out in the same way that Redzepi
does like they just used what's around
them to kind of and they're and they're
doing it like throughout the day hey I
have ten minutes I'm gonna go you know
I'm gonna do some handstands or whatever
it is and they're just constantly move
super high-energy dudes amazing yeah you
know what check these guys out I would
like to you know it's funny with Rene
Redzepi a lot of his menus is foraged
ingredients from the wild or
herbs and beach grasses and whatnot you
didn't even know you were edible and in
fact are often highly nutritious in his
workout and the foraging are similar in
the sense that they're free right I mean
he's is there it's just there you don't
have to pay his store for you don't have
to pay a gym he I think that his
philosophy is inspiring and is
influential but it's also cheap right
unless you're eating it at Noma he's
cool he's getting extremely high-end
ingredients that are flown in from
Norway and the Faroe Islands and
everything but a lot of his other
ingredients are either fermented things
that they just make on their own that
take years and and things that are
foraged and he's very different you know
one of the things I'm trying to
communicate to people who've heard about
this book is when they hear about chefs
they tend to think about excess they
tend to think about you know truffles
and caviar and that kind of champagne
adult chances indulgences at me let Noma
is really not about that there there's a
sense of luxury and that you're being
taken care of
there are bytes that are extraordinary
extraordinarily delicious but it's very
much a break from that fatty excessive
kind of cooking and in fact the the menu
that's about to drop at the end of this
month at the end of in over the the
summer is the plant kingdom menu so they
have three main menus at Noma in the in
the sort of winter the colder months
it's a seafood menu and in the fall it's
sort of a wild game menu but the the
main menu for the senton this sort of
middle of the year is plant Kingdom and
it's all vegetables and fruits and herbs
and roots and things like that that are
offered in just an exceptionally
delicious way I showed you a picture
right beforehand you show me this image
on Instagram of one of the dishes a
plate and it was the most beautiful
presentation of food I've ever seen yeah
and not cliched not those swoops and
dashes and little ant hills of powder
like just these vegetables and herbs and
flowers present it as they are in their
natural beauty right probably brushed
with some beautiful fermented sauce but
you can leave Noma
feeling quite light
you know and feeling quite healthy and
it's not some five hour endurance test
either I mean it tends to go pretty
quickly and they just make you feel good
and the food makes you feel good right
it's part of why I've kept going back
I've now eaten there six times it'll be
my seventh time in a few weeks it's
because it's always different and they
kind of just blow up the menu every few
months and create something entirely new
well let's contextualize this whole
thing a little bit no sorry I will yeah
yeah no it's cool
but that's it you've got this book
hungry and it's essentially part memoir
part adventure story yeah seeing through
the lens of Rene Redzepi who's heralded
as the greatest chef in the world as a
result of this restaurant Noma that he
has in Copenhagen and he's known for his
like we said earlier like you know being
hyper local and and and hit this network
of foragers that bring him these amazing
ingredients and he has this you know
genius touch when it comes to creating
new and different kinds of flavors and
this restaurant Noma became this crazy
phenomenon but what drew you to this guy
as a story like what what you know why
write a book about Rene Redzepi like how
did this whole thing come together I
love that leaves of grass is right in
front of me I'm just gonna point that
yeah you can read it you can I don't we
can we can don't tell me from that
doesn't want that I would do it but um
well you are a poet no I'm right about
talking about us but I five years ago
almost exactly five years ago I met Rene
Redzepi I was in a dark period in my own
life I was extremely depressed I was in
the middle of a marital separation and I
had just moved into a crummy little
bachelor apartment no matter how you
slice it
divorce is brutal it was it was just as
it was a sad night there were a lot of
Tears there was a lot there uh there was
a lot of gnawing on the past and guilt
and into this moment I checked my email
and it was about a week later maybe ten
days later into this moment Rene Redzepi
appears through an operative that fide
on who was
a publishing house that was putting out
some of his books they were like you
know Renee's gonna be in New York he
wants to meet the greatest chef in the
world wants to meet you
right you know so I'm like no I'm good
I'm busy I don't want to hear this guy I
don't want to sit down and have him
prattle on to me about his manifesto and
like the thing about the New Nordic
movement is we believe I'm just like I
don't have the bandwidth I just want to
go home you know it makes no sense from
a journalistic standpoint but the
deadlines of the New York Times are
crushing you're always always dead when
I was working on a piece about you
I was probably working on 10 other
pieces at the same time and in fact had
just come back from Korea for junk so I
was exhausted I said yes anyway cuz
we'll see what did I am curious what why
do you think that he sought you out I'm
not sure that question keeps coming on
you'd written some semi critical things
about I fired about he liked my writing
maybe but he also I had written a piece
for the New York Times sort of mocking
the New Nordic movement in New York it's
manifestations in New York and I think
he has a way of identifying obstructions
and and reaching out to those
obstructions and perhaps pulling them
into his orbit I met a guy in Detroit
who had worked at Noma Mexico one of the
Noma pop-ups yeah and I said do you ever
get the sense that Rene Redzepi is kind
of like a benevolent cult leader and
this guy hit the floor laughing he's
like you just [ __ ] nailed it that is
it he's like a cult leader like you
can't resist
he's extremely charismatic and he is
this extreme sense of mission it's a
little like Tom Cruise we were talking
about before he's focused on you he has
so many profound things to say about
nature and food and the environment and
his own life story and you're just kind
of captivated not everyone has that
degree of focus and communication and
that kind of weird energy I felt like I
was meeting David Bowie in the 70s
uh-huh or Bob Dylan in the 60s or Steve
Jobs in the 80s yeah you what Mayotte
say now like I felt like I was meeting
somebody
absolutely catalytic in the culture
David Byrne absolutely David Byrne who's
a reference and the right actually all
the chapters are named after Talking
Heads songs so I was like wow this guy I
see why it's the best chef in the world
I mean he's completely catalytic leader
and he was like oh you know you're an LA
guy cuz I grew up out here you know and
he's like you know you like tacos you
talked of course I like what yet you get
you're from Denver tell me about it I
can see I am NOT from Mexico but let me
tell you something I grew up with au
katakan restaurant down the street that
could have told you about cochinita
pibil when I was 15
you know like yeah let's let's talk
tacos mister Copenhagen but guess what
he was like yeah you know that's awesome
like you and I should go through Mexico
on a taco trip and you know it's like
what sure I mean that's not gonna happen
what are you talking about right just
throwing yeah so I keep hitting the mic
sorry sorry listeners um but I was like
there's no budget for that and um so it
turns out that he's very persuasive in
that cult leader way he's very
persistent and he would text me he would
email me how's the Mexico trip coming
along I was like there is no Mexico trip
Rene let it go you know but he keep oh
come on we should go it'll be fun
one time it's true story I was in it
it's not in the book but I was in an
elevator with Whitney Vargas who was a
former editor of mine at details
magazine great person great editor and
she said what are you working on I said
whit you know I'm not working on the
best story ever I'm supposed to go
through Mexico with Rene Redzepi she's
like to know him a guy like the great
chef in the world guys like yeah he's
like obsessed with Mexico he wants to go
on a like a travel piece taco quest
she's like we'll do it you can do it for
T magazine mm-hmm I was like what yeah
she's like we'll send you a you know
agreement or something and I was like
okay elevator gets off of this like the
elevator pitch you know right I get off
of the 6th floor walk back down to the
fourth floor where I worked texted Renee
is like looks like we're going to Mexico
and he's like I know he's like I knew
this would happen
yeah that's how he is like he won't take
no for an answer
he's he and you know you have that you
just feel like you're being coaxed you
know but in a good way
it's and so then after a while I mean I
did that piece but then after a while I
just went to normal on my own spent my
own money
with Lauren who's now my wife I went
with my friend Ian I would just you know
they would just little blurp would
happen on my texts or my emails like you
have a reservation at Noma take it or
leave it
in a certain point I was like I do not
have the money for this I do not have
the time for this I do not have the
emotional bandwidth for this let's do it
let's just say yes let's go to Sydney
let's go to Copenhagen again and it
started to become intoxicating it was
like I was self-medicating with Noma you
know right this is a way like in many
ways the book is is about I mean it
sounds trite to say midlife crisis but
oh it's about acting you know it's about
you know it's about like how do you
navigate a difficult time it's about
reinvention it's about you know not
being afraid to you know face difficult
challenges and and and embracing like
the unknown which absolutely is
happening in your own life and is
mirrored in the experience that Redzepi
is having with trying to you know
continually reinvent himself yeah what
dovetailed nicely was that my life was
in flux and I was adrift and his life
not so much in flux but he was sort of
blowing it up
he had this restaurant Noma we've seen
almost unanimously is the most
influential restaurant the world so he
decided to close it right and tear it
down and build a brand new Noma on what
looked like an abandoned junk heap in
Grenoble like I mean I can't tell you
how it's like dealing going electric
dude thank you
it is like that's what it's supposed to
be like I think I think Dylan the Dylan
documentary Don't Look Back was in some
ways a model for what I wanted to do the
one with da Pennebaker made when we were
kings with Muhammad Ali right these
documentaries that capture a pivotal
figure and culture in at a moment at the
at a pivotal moment in his or her path
right and I thought I have that path I
have it I have access he's closing the
original Noma building a new one it's an
impossible task it's like something out
of a
Hertzog movie really while he's doing
this pop up in the jungle he's doing a
pop up in Australia he's got this whole
wild food initiative in Denmark he's got
three children he's he's his life is
nuts
yeah and it's like Dylan in the 60s I
mean like a certain point this periods
gonna end there'll be like the
motorcycle accident or whatever it'll
come to an end so like I wanna that was
sort of my pitch to right if it's like
if Verner Hertzog's not gonna make a
movie about you're the guy you're gonna
be you're gonna have to be it's gonna
fall onto you to chronicle this I
thought I have to do it yeah but I also
let it be fun
and I thought readers would enjoy
getting the contact high from Renee that
I do but you know what you've totally
blown my mind though because I actually
did the audiobook myself because I
thought you know it's my story I should
do it turns out I should not have put
all those Danish and Spanish words in
there like I did I have to name every
chil I ever because I'm sitting there
like Sheila like I was like oh no do it
again do it again they made these Danish
accent on every single one of these yes
but now I realize it should have been
Verna Hertz I would have been genius oh
my god you would have had to pay that
guy to do it I wake up on a beach sand
in my eyes oh that was so good
you know the midlife crisis thing I
tried to just kind of go straight out
that obviously that's a that's a
long-standing cliche yeah it does happen
though it happens everyone men women all
different ages right and the reason it
begins super pretentiously with Dante's
Divine Comedy opening to that right now
and then lament you give the nod to it
immediately yeah the reason is because I
don't know how much you know about
Dante's Divine Comedy I did a whole
class in college just about the Dante's
Divine Comedy and la Vita Nuova
this other piece but this other work
about Beatrice a from Dante anyway it
can be read as a political metaphor a
theological tract just a work of poetry
it can also very easily be read as a
metaphor for a midlife crisis because
the opening lines of Dante's Divine
Comedy are essentially they've kind of
loosely translate in the middle of the
way of my life I found myself in a dark
jungle and I didn't know the way out
right that is so I wasn't just being
pretentious although I am really good
yeah that's just when they need to be
but I know it's kind of winking at that
because then as you turn the page I'm
lying there passed out next to a sea
turtle sanctuary on a beach um pretty
much in the same state that Dante was
where I met Virgil like laterally adrift
yeah just like where am I going like um
I was also just exhausted from our
somehow visiting like four cities in one
day it's really but that I thought you
know the book doesn't have an
introduction on purpose like I could
have done the whole introduction about
like let me introduce you to Rene
Redzepi and I I hate that to me that's
like a Berlin wall between you and the
reader like just start the damn thing
just start the book uh-huh I've talked
to a lot of people like in food writing
for instance people who are like I don't
know ma'am I was a little weary of Noma
I don't know if I need to read about
Rene Redzepi anymore and you know this
kind of hero worship
they read like three or four pages and
they seem to get sucked in and a lot of
people are like wait this is a very
different book than I anticipated
because it's not it's not supposed to be
just bros you know and I'm just like
endlessly raising a toast to the
excellence of Rene Redzepi I admire the
man considerably I do think he has many
heroic elements but he's also human and
his flaws come through I think his
temper the difficulty of bringing Noma
Mexico together toward the end you'll
see he kind of has you know near
breakdown so I think it ended up being a
little more complex than that and and
and that I didn't want to put myself in
the book originally but my reinvention
my passages toward different modes of
understanding or whatever we're actually
important to why I wanted to do it you
know he reinvented his restaurant he
reinvented himself he reinvented the
whole way Noma cooks I suspect there's a
lot of folks in like Silicon Valley you
know interested in disruption and create
you know creative destruction and those
themes would probably find themselves
drawn to this narrative because Rene
does that sort of thing himself with the
restaurant that's why it remains vital
but I
doing the same thing with my own life
and just trying to figure out where I
was gonna go yeah but you like me
these reinventions usually are forged in
the crucible of pain like we we have
some something destructive happens in
our lives that forces us to confront
ourselves in an uncomfortable way oh
that's right we have no real choice but
to try to find a new way forward but
then you have someone like Rosetti who's
like at the peak of their powers who's
like I'm gonna cast this away I'm gonna
reinvent myself now when all the
pressure and all the energy is around
maintaining what's already been created
and that takes a very unique level of
vision and courage to you know blaze a
path like that but it's interesting if
we think about these people I've brought
up as potential comparisons David Bowie
Bob Dylan baby I didn't Steve Jobs
Muhammad Ali
changed his name and we're talking about
people who change their identity change
their practice change their whole
creative vision all the time and we're
still talking about them they're still
vital in the culture the people who do
one thing consistently I raise a toast
to them but oftentimes we grow bored
with it like and and the conversation
doesn't continue so I found that
intoxicating to be around you know and I
thought that I mean he's whole like it's
if he's tied to nature his the food he
cooks is tied to nature foraging
fermenting and all that but also his
philosophy his philosophy is essentially
everything changes all the time it's
like some George Harrison [ __ ] like we
are always in flux that's that's nature
as well like exactly nature happened
like she was hitting the mic
but I get so pumped about this because
it's exactly right like the cycles of
nature are woven into the way the whole
enterprise of nomal works like the last
lines of the book that's readers will
see our it can change it can change it
can change he's talking about the new
Noma that he's finally succeeded in
building but even that he sees as being
in it
Colonel state of metamorphosis like the
menu changes and the staff changes and
they'll suddenly have a completely
different vision I mean there are a lot
of people in the book who float in and
out Danny Bowen from Mission Chinese
food right that guy's a character yeah
and he's very vulnerable and honest as
people see Enric Olivera
a Kylie Kwong jessica Koslow makes an
appearance Dave Chang appears toward the
end and you know one note from my editor
early on was these people kind of appear
but then they vanish and I was like
uh-huh that's that's what it is to be in
this guy's at worry about exactly and
that's the truth that's the natural
truth too is like people float in an
hour out of our lives it was almost to
me a little like the Canterbury Tales
like we're kind of walking down the road
and we meet interesting people along the
way and sometimes they circle back then
sometimes they don't the book originally
I'll tell you something that I haven't
talked about with with anyone is that
the book originally had a section about
my own depression that was much much
darker like it it went there mm-hmm and
I think it was a spectacular piece of
writing actually about how you know how
dark he got for me and my editors to
their credit and I respect their
viewpoint of this just felt they'd had
it totally did not fit with the rest of
the book it was like suddenly it took
such a dark turn that it was almost
off-putting and confusing I may use that
as a separate piece on its own someday
but I think the only downside of that
not being present as some people are
like I don't really understand the
degree of stuckness or drift it
punctuates the journey to have that
right moment in there yeah it's it's
it's now it's a little more vague people
like I don't quite know what your tie
was really down you know you know Tony
Bourdain down Wow and a lot of people
struggle with that yeah yeah so I mean
one of the things I'm grappling with
it's a little bit of a shift but my
predecessor at Esquire magazine Joshua
Ozersky incredible talent incredible
food writer very provocative
a lot of hot takes pissed off a lot of
people I disagreed with him furiously
all the time but he was a tremendous
talent he died you know he died in
Chicago in 2015 I believe while at being
in Chicago for the James Beard Awards he
had some health issues I gather and had
a seizure Anthony Bourdain is gone right
Jonathan gold is gone
Anthony AAA Gill ass incredible British
food writer he's actually he met he's
mentioned the book he essentially dies
in the book he was one of Rene's friends
also an incredible talent somewhat
problematic writer but but from a pro
standpoint exhilarating different
reasons behind each of the passings and
different factors altogether but as
somebody who's a professional food
writer you gotta be crazy if you don't
think I'm thinking this through yeah and
all of those people were super
influential on you right you're
absolutely specially Jonathan gold to be
honest I mean when I was growing up in
LA and I was at late teens is when Ruth
Rachel took over food writing and
editing at the Los Angeles Times and
Jonathan gold started writing
counterintelligence I don't remember the
precise moment if I was still in high
school or it was in college obviously
this pre-internet so I'd come back from
college but I thought they were just
revolutionary figures Jonathan and and
Ruth and they both of them changed how I
thought about Los Angeles changed how I
thought about food changed how I thought
about writing and like what I grew up a
very conservative environment San Marino
you know and and so poetry punk rock and
food in some ways opened my
consciousness yeah
but I'm you know I have babies
I have five to one year olds Jasper and
Wesley and I have two teenagers I want
to keep ticking for a while you know I
want to be round so I'm trying to learn
how to do this line of work with some
degree of moderation and your common
sense I have trouble with a big bowl of
deliciousness I have a lot of trouble
saying no I still remember
to comment no but I mean people drawn to
food writing often have it to an acute
degree
they're almost like alcoholics who
becomes booze writers you know like
we're drawn right to the flame and and I
remember talking to you about your
dietary changes and you used to eat a
lot of junk food and stuff right and I
remember you talking about dairy being
the hardest thing to shake that was
almost like heroin or something like a
loft area and hope I'm that miss Merman
yeah now it's that's correct and I I
find that to be that that wants me
you're saying that I think about it a
lot because I I have I also have foods
that I react poorly to I don't seem to
react well Daddario get things like spa
you know big honest with you and and I
don't feel it's healthy and yet I have
to try everything on menus and have to
do my due diligence and respect the
chefs the pastry chefs etc but I'm
grappling with it yeah that puts you in
a precarious situation having to do all
that but but but I look at you as
somebody who is not in the world that
you're in because you have some sort of
you know gluttonous impulse like you're
you approach food from a perspective of
culture it's interesting to hear that
that the seeds of your intrigue with
with food and cuisine were planted so
early because food you know being a food
and drinks writer was not the original
path for you like we're in music and
you're in movies and and you did a lot
of things in journalism literature and
writing before you know kind of the
Epiphany like brought you back to food
you have an interesting story around
that that I'm that I'd like to have you
tell but your your your lens is not
through taste and flavor it's through
cultural import and impact right yeah
like when you made that transition from
writing about bands and music into food
it was because there was a cultural
shift in how we perceived that world
that kind of displaced music for you oh
yeah absolutely
you're such a good interviewer I'm sorry
to know flattered but I'd like to you is
so true I mean there are writers
historically like AJ Liebling or even
Jim Harrison
the poet novelist also was a food
columnist at Esquire Jim Harrison was
one of my predecessors guys giant I know
it's crazy yeah I have a book of his
poetry in my bag in the car here
those guys were very much about excess
it was like and then we went to the
restaurant we ordered an entire roast
lamb and a roast chicken and all the
foie gras and you know I'm not that kind
of food right I'm not drawn to that I
don't like the romanticization of that
I'm mostly interested in the cultural
conversation and the people and what it
struck me as there used to be a time
when the musicians that you liked were
emblematic of something about your
belief system they were emblems of your
identity you know like I liked Elvis
Costello and the jam and Grandmaster
Flash and the Beastie Boys whatever this
is an emblematic generationally and
maybe of yeah you know the where you are
in in the marketplace or the culture of
ideas um that's still true I have a 16
year old daughter who's a songwriter and
bands are incredibly important to her we
go to show us all the time but it did
shift for me and I think it's shifted
for a lot of people in American culture
and suddenly it was about what David
Chang is saying and Dan barber at Blue
Hill at Stone Barns and Rene Redzepi and
Dominique Ren and Amanda Cohen and
Mahama Bailey and all these different
figures over the last 15 20 years became
avatars of the cultural conversation in
the way that Janis Joplin and Jimi
Hendrix and Bob Dylan used to be or for
our generation you know REM and talk my
dad's used to be and food dovetails so
perfectly with environmental concerns
political issues cultural conversations
about backstories and roots family roots
your your grandmother's story and ever
there's so much in food everyone eats no
matter what their system of eating and
and so yeah I was getting I was getting
I was aging out of being in music right
all right I would be like oh you know I
love all the new bands I love Arcade
Fire and people like you know they're
like 15 years old and I was like
oh they're not a new banner like white
stripes they're new right no they're
like a quarter century I'll tell you how
much I relate to that like the exact
same age so for me yeah Elvis Costello
I mean REM was like everything that me
you know anything that IRS was putting
out sure what's interesting is yeah The
Clash like that whole era and I really
remember this is interesting because San
Marino is such a conservative town it
seemed to kind of produce a generation
of counterculture kids in our in our
from our from our synthesis era right
percept Kirk Roche was one of those
people like comes out of San Marino high
he's a swimmer he's very there's a lot
of traditional aspects to his upbringing
very conservative parents and yet he was
like a cipher for me for new music like
he his sister was super punk rock I
don't know if he knew her in high school
introduced me to all these bands and you
know then it was English speed and you
know you know and it just went on and on
from there but I learned a lot from that
guy alone coming from San Marino it's
one of the few upside they're like oh I
can listen to reckoning you know again
and again and again and again and again
and I have such a difficult time
connecting with anything it's relevant
now it dude this isn't this amazing
conversation thank you yeah you know you
know this Sam you know context I try to
tell this to some people and they don't
really believe that it's hard for them
to understand in New York kind of
conservative
yeah a town like this is you know like I
mean we had members of Reagan's cabinet
across my streets at the John Birch
Society literally lived across the
street okay so yeah it formed one of the
few upsides of forms a very strong
countercultural element in the kids who
just don't want any part of that right
and so there were all sorts of people in
my school particularly when I was a
freshman Erik Varner Teresa Marshall
Grant miner some folks who were gay and
out in a very conservative school which
is a powerful statement at that point
particularly when I was going to like
for Bible studies a week and stuff
people were me Grant was a punk-rocker
and Penelope Spheeris movies and stuff
and in a band with flea and I you know
and these were like mentors to me I mean
Eric Varner is now I think professor of
classics at Emory
as this kid this guy who like introduced
me to Bowie and interest in me Iggy Pop
and then X and fear and all these bands
I mean acts as a parent I was big yeah I
mean particularly here in Southern
California you know and you know my life
was it was changed when a bunch of these
folks took me to see The Clash at the
Hollywood Palladium I saw The Clash I
think on the sandanista tour maybe I was
in war State open how do you know that
cuz I know my [ __ ] with this stuff dude
the English speed open yeah how was
Anna's on the most instance the most
like iridescent moment of my life
I was completely levitated I had never
felt anything like this it was like oh
no this is church this is church I was
lifted off the ground
hmm um because the crowd had packed in
so high that we were but like when I
left my shirt was so sweaty that I
remember actually ringing it like a
dishtowel you know and and the beat was
out of control ranking Rogers recently
passed away which right but like The
Clash you know your 14 year old kids are
susceptible to this but they had like
the Union Jack rolled down and they
started playing Toccata and Fugue by
Bach like the organ think Danny Danny
it's like the Dracula music and then
they come out and just burst into London
Calling
as I remember it it may have been
something else I'm so bored at the USA
ourselves but I I saw it was I sitting
there like oh my god I don't know what
they were talking about politically I
never quite unraveled that I mean I
gather they were from the laughter but
it it wasn't that it was the sense of
liberation it would a sense of thinking
for yourself that was so much about Punk
so much what punk rock was about right
but exactly as you're saying like that
was a that was because I bonded with
kids on campus who are the thinker's and
you know the progressives and the people
challenging the status quo and they're
still to this day my friends I mean I
saw I saw Grant miner last summer in
Laguna Beach and we hung out a little
bit and I don't think I would have been
a writer
had that not happened I mean also going
up to Romans bookstore in Pasadena and
randomly buying Howell by Allen Ginsberg
and frank O'Hara poems and Lawrence
Ferlinghetti all the beats stuff
obviously when you're kid that's like
that's a really mesmerize electric
kool-aid acid test only you know
yeah it's Tom Wolfe was a big influence
on my life and I I think part of what I
wanted to do with hungry actually is
write a book that won't be assigned at
school mm-hmm you know like when like
you go into a used book store and you'd
find an old Tom Wolfe paperback the
right stuff for radical chic or
something
and it just seemed fun to read yeah
you're like they're not teaching there
there's a sign in the Scarlet Letter and
all that I want I want a book that I
hope like people in their teens and 20s
just pick up for fun you know and they
could read in a day and it's what you
can it's only like 200 pages yes energy
there's a there's an electric kool-aid
acid test quote in the book about the
whole Ken Kesey gang in the bus because
we were about to get her on that you're
kind of on this bus I was on a similar
bus going through Mexico with the you
know consciousness expanding crew of
Noma so I thought let's make the
reference explicit cuz that I'm not a
ping Tom Wolfe there but I he was a
clear influence right and I think it's
um but that's I just I just thought this
please let this not be boring you know
like I just hate boring books it's
definitely not it moves quickly I'm not
done with it yet maybe it's boring but I
don't know it doesn't get going gets
better
and there there is a you know there's a
lyrical poetry in your writing I mean I
know you studied poetry and that's a
that's a big interest of you you're an
avid consumer of poetry but there's like
there's a lyricism to the prose but it's
always very accessible like you have a
very kind of pure clean way of writing
you don't get caught up in your own ego
about how to turn a catchy phrase I hope
not
I hope that's a little bit of a
byproduct of experience yeah I think
that I I remember that's the journalist
yeah I remember reading somebody like
Wallace Stegner years ago saying that
when you're when you're starting out you
want to
be you're sort of like a walking
thesaurus you want to show off your
words everyone I've got big words look
at me you know and I remember thinking
yeah you just can't do that man like him
like I could deliver the fireworks watch
you know the arrogance of youth but a
lot of writers lots seem to talk about
the beauty of simplicity clarity and
minimalism as they get older
I'm 52 I get it now I really see why
there's delight in that and why it's
harder it's harder to do they're both
hard but but there's something there's
something very satisfying about direct
clear sentences and and also when you
factor in reality that most people are
just inundated with distractions they
don't have a lot of time to read you you
really grab in people by the neck and
saying please read this and that's the
truth
so it has to be captivating for them
otherwise you know you're giving them
homework that's the thing I don't want
it to be homework so that's come up a
couple I've had a couple authors in here
recently and they've all kind of echo
the same sentiment like when you're
asking somebody to read your book like
now today in this culture within the age
of distraction it's a big ask you're
saying I need you to set aside whatever
it is that you're doing and in an
undistracted way sit down with these
pages that I've written and you know you
better deliver the goods yeah they're
gonna make that request on someone yeah
yeah they better have they better have
some sort of take away to you know so
when you're a kid and you're seeing the
clash and English beat and yeah you know
um all of that a kid the three o'clock
it was our I was that old like Paisley
underground scene was happening so I was
really into the that stuff right
particularly the three o'clock I saw a
bunch of times X yeah it was just like
you know it's dirty it's raw it's alive
in a way that seemed like an antidote to
what was antiseptic about San Marino
culture or whatever I mean I could I
could paint that town with a broad brush
and be just critical but of course
that's that's not fair I mean I have a
lot of friends from San Marino I have
friends uh you
on the conservative side of the aisle
who are still friends and I we just
disagree you know we disagree pretty
aggressively on Facebook or whatever but
I mean pretty [ __ ] we've dropped a few
you know if you didn't make the cut
after a while but but you know some I
could meet him for breakfast and we
laugh we have a good time you know and
it's so did you have a sense that you
wanted to be a writer at that age yeah
you did
which is ridiculous I don't know why I
don't know why you know I don't I think
some people are drawn to writing because
they have a pulsing gnawing need to tell
a specific story right could be a story
of pain from their youth of abuse it
could be an immigrant story that
involves a lot of challenges and uphill
battles I mean that speaking candidly
I'm not coming from that place I I was
drawn to books because I loved language
I just loved stories I loved sentences I
found them exhilarating
like the Lawrence Ferlinghetti book or a
frank O'Hara book I liked that the words
were jumping all over the page I liked
that they were breaking the rules of
punctuation and grammar that was that
seemed fun that seemed kind of punk rock
like you know and I just I I started to
see you know Joan Didion Tom Wolfe Gay
Talese John McPhee who was a teacher of
mine in college they would do these
incredible pieces for magazines that
sometimes profiles of stars but
sometimes more reported essays about
cultural movements or whatever I thought
wow that's a-- that's one hell the job i
mean it's basically subsidized adventure
mm-hmm like you get to weigh in on the
culture you get to move the needle you
get to meet all these captivating people
and somebody else pays you let's do that
there was a golden era where magazines
really you know led the way in total
those kinds of think pieces from you
know yeah like Joan Didion gore Vidal
and normal email or Norton exactly
normal Efron James Baldwin wrote for
Esquire I mean as far yeah Esquire was
really the tip of the spear when it came
to that I mean Vanity Fair was like that
for a while and for whatever
Esquire has sort of survived the
collapse of the magazine industry I mean
but you know how I can't imagine how
difficult it is to remain relevant in
this culture as a magazine like it's a
dying thing and yet
Esquire seemed to have figured out a way
to survive and still maintain some
foothold in that you know in an era in
which that's being disintegrated
we hope yeah knock on wood you know it's
nice it the same as their a sense of
like we had were responsible for
shepherding this legacy there's
definitely a sense of responsibility to
regarding this this the heritage of the
magazine and all the incredible by lines
that have been in in you know dispatches
from Vietnam Nora Ephron's original
column everything from it's very dark
disturbing investigative pieces to some
of the best light entertaining reading
ever and budgets are tight I'm not gonna
lie yeah you know like I have money
there's their use I have to really make
my case anytime a vision visiting a city
for Esquire best new restaurants
research or something we find ways to
make it work speaking candidly when I
went to New Orleans
Pablo Johnson a friend of mine I slept
on his couch when I went to San
Francisco
Omar Mamoon mm-hmm let me his apartment
I mean if it was 1978 they wouldn't put
me up at the Ritz yeah like I would have
been up a knob yeah you know at the
Fairmount or whatever the top of the
mark you know like it way I mean in fact
I even experienced that in the 90s it
was pretty profligate I stayed at the
best hotels in the world they would just
send me to them so um hey you don't need
that to me what's important is the work
you know and and uh you know I'll tell
you this is interesting like I should
have brought one but I the the recent
issue that's out the summer issue has
Brad Pitt Leo DiCaprio and Quentin
Tarantino on the comer has our best bars
issue it has just one page after another
no filler really good stuff and I'll
give this issue to people and they'll
say oh my god this is a blast to spend
time with like I really enjoy it I'm
like yes it's called a magazine yeah
here's how you operate it you turned in
the table of contents and that tells you
where the you know
right my bharata rant is in there and it
has a kind of throwback aesthetic to it
like it is there's a vintage you have
architecture to the design yeah
which looks beautiful I I'm I don't know
how that plays in the marketplace I
think they're still trying to figure
that out you know there's a way in which
you can be almost to backwards looking
but we'll we'll see if that works out I
mean I idea that I get out of it is we
may not have the budgets to put you up
at top of the mark or the Ritz but this
if you want to write long form and you
want to preach if you appreciate and
love reading long form like we're the
place for that yeah and yeah in The New
Yorker I mean something I'm not aiming
it for the luxury that I'm really not I
mean it to do this work as long as
they'll let me until they kick me off
the bus I really am I'm just running out
the clock
okay I'm 52 I figure like I'm gonna do
this as far as I can because it brings
me joy and I stay I stay young to be
honest I mean I'm raised learning the
coolest thing about it is I'm always
learning I'm always meeting people I go
to new restaurants I meet the chefs I I
meet cultural figures and I learned from
them I go to a new city all the time you
know there's our Talking Heads song
cities find me a new city to live in
like I find that it's so exciting to
just drop into Seoul Korea or Buenos
Aires or Modena Italy or Memphis or
Phoenix or Chicago maybe a city I
haven't spent any time in Minneapolis I
want to have never been there before
last year The Replacements Prince you
know Bob Dylan for Minnesota Lake and to
absorb the energy of that city and learn
what makes it tick learn some history
like I'll give you an example I went to
Minneapolis and my wife was like you
should reach out to Andrew Zimmern you
know that Bizarre Foods guy from Ryan D
and it's like really I mean he's like a
celebrity why would he want to hang with
me but he he was he was so nice to email
back like the outlets get dinner so I
sat down for dinner and many out he
lives there he lives him and you sat
down with uh as I think Dan buta you did
your you went to his place there didn't
you know him in New York
oh you did he's awesome he's
the Blue Zones books are pivotal Dan's
the greatest yeah he's a good guy but
Zimmerman was like oh do you know all
about this element of Minneapolis
history in this element and you know
he's like a storehouse of information
that's the luxury that's actually luxury
it's not some fancy hotel it's somebody
teaching you something I'm sort of like
a perpetual student mm-hmm that's why it
was exciting to meet you and come here
like and to learn about your life it's
just I find other people's lives
instantly fascinating and when I didn't
you were asking about being a writer I
mean when I started I went to college
and I wrote some poems but I started
writing short stories and I even want
some fiction prize whatever but and you
got to study with Russell banks Russell
banks Joyce Carol Oates yeah but but the
mindful fiction was fine but I think it
was all where the tank was already
running empty I didn't have a lot to say
my life had been pretty copacetic pretty
mellow actually and and when I took it
class with John McPhee from The New
Yorker it turned my head around because
he's a nonfiction
master and he opened my eyes to the
simplicity of you write about other
people you're good at listening to
people you'll get out like hearing their
stories and asking them questions in a
very I think uh Nanoha unobtrusive way
and if you have an appetite for that the
sky's the limit because there's always
new people to meet and talk about so
that's really what set me on the path I
mean like I was so into music and it was
like wait I can meet them and write
about them like I mean I met David Bowie
twice I interviewed him Willie Nelson I
went on the bus with him and yes we did
smoke van Morrison who was odious yeah I
heard you telling story about that
sounded horrible he was a nightmare you
know Green Day Janet Jackson all sorts
of people it was you know it I'm not
that I don't do selfies with them I
don't I don't like I'm not like well
cool and hang it was Willie Nelson it's
not like that you know I must have
pinch-me moments like I can't believe
yeah I'm having this almost famous you
know sort of experience yeah getting to
live vicariously you know through the
lives of these people that you get to
pop in and out of you know at well
almost
yeah pinch me is a good description for
it because like people have asked me
don't you have any actually my
publishing house there you must have
selfies with Rene and I was like no in
five years I've never done a selfie with
Rene oh I'm not like that you know so
but Willie Nelson for instance partly
the bus was absolutely B fogged with pot
smoke so what's working in a weird way
but I was like well that face is Willie
Nelson's face and it's looking at me and
it's talking in that distinctive Willie
Nelson voice is this real what is
happening it's a little like quantum
leap that show where the guy would just
be like suddenly beamed into the French
Revolution beamed into like that Boston
Tea Party or something like I would sit
there like how did I get how did I get
here back to a David Byrne is this
occurring or am I dreaming
it has happened many times happen with
Tom Cruise at the Japanese restaurant
when everybody looks like Tom Cruise
he looks remarkably similar to Tom
Cruise that you must have had
experiences you know they say never meet
your heroes where it's disappointing
I guess the Van Morrison thing is
probably that was disappointed even
though he was was that you know we can
be heroes just for one day he really
both both times absolute gentleman
really and you know it's interesting
both times he was early as you might
have noticed I'm often Harley I was
couldn't believe it like I walk into the
room or a studio or something where it's
gonna interview Bowie the second time
and he was already there he's like hey
Jeff how are you you know and I'm like
oh my god that was a joint interview
with Moby because they were doing some
collaborations or something and they
were for the cover of the Entertainment
Weekly
I'm proud to say I remember that what
you did I'm proud to say we got Bowie on
the cover because I felt he deserved it
and we were always going for the younger
audience but he's like well we really
shouldn't start the interview until Moby
shows up but why don't you and I just
talk uh-huh just talk to David Bowie to
me just
okay well tell me about Fripp's guitar
sound on heroes you know like I mean I
yeah I'm gonna fanboy like mad dude you
don't want this you don't want me to
just talk to you huh
cuz I'll lose my [ __ ] you know I'm
obsessed
we have David Bowie portrait in our
house we actually bought one in
Copenhagen Lauren and I I mean we we are
a Bowie house shrine a little battery we
have Bowie fridge magnets
you know we're into the guy and but yeah
there were some people you know a lot of
times it was the younger crowd coming up
like I remember Green Day being a little
aggro with the interview and it's like a
certain I mean I I really liked them and
admire them now and do boys like oh
you're you're Entertainment Weekly like
we're too edgy for that yeah man you're
perceptive I think that day a little bit
of friction you know at four it became a
Broadway show yeah someday soon Billy
Joe I have something to tell you you're
gonna be on Broadway so don't give me
any attitude no I mean I like them quite
a bit actually but they were really
young and they were breaking through and
there's so much stress when Dookie was
becoming this huge and at a certain
point a certain point Billy Joe it's
kind of kind of lecturing me about the
Ramones
and I was like yeah so I'm gonna turn
off the tape recorder for a second um
let me just tell you a little bit about
myself because I know I know I look very
square but I was into the Ramones when
you were a baby it was fine but you know
it's an interesting story
my daughter is into a band called
swimmers fwm RS we have seen three times
they are rad they are a punk rock band
from Oakland we first time we saw on
Providence Rhode Island all-ages show
Marga was probably 13 I drove her up to
Providence just to see his bands
probably 20 people in the audience the
guys from the band came down from the
stage just meet everybody was like so
low-key now they're becoming big stars
they
the drummer of swimmers is Billie Joe
Armstrong son Wow that's how old we yeah
that now I'm really feeling green these
kids have bands they after this is over
we're gonna have to go listen to some
pavement I follow your girlfriend yeah
so they so they are now the next
generation the children of Green Day
like I was like wow okay why we got to
face facts now but this is that this is
a weird twist max Becker
one of the guys and swimmers started
posting on his Instagram story little
frame grabs of my pieces from Esquire
because it turns out that the guys and
swimmers are obsessed with food hmm
and then he he was like you know all
this column is so cool and I want to
make this recipe and I was like just
amazing so I am dim I was like hey
that's so nice and he's like oh that's
yeah I'm a big fan of your writing I
couldn't believe this Wow
yeah and I was like well you're not
gonna believe this dude but I have seen
swimmers three times because he was like
I'm gonna be in called swimmers I was
like yeah I know I've seen you yeah and
he was so shocked he was like you've
seen swimmers like in my daughters like
you'd like like actually your first man
and we have seen you three times and now
I like text with max all the time like
he's looking for a restaurant to eat at
and stuff like that so um I was thinking
about bringing him to Noma that's a cool
that would be a cool store yeah I think
it really just validates this full
circle thing that we were talking about
originally this intersection you know in
terms of cultural significance between
music and food it's interesting to me
that the guys in the band are more in
the bands are more interested in chefs
now uh-huh you know it's fascinating to
me it's a strange thing
it's strange like the guy at Franz
Ferdinand like one of those guys had a
food blog for a while I was in there's a
do you know grizzly bear oh yeah so
Chris from grizzly bear who's a friend
of ours wrote has a cookbook that's
right that's right yeah I mean we're
into food it's all it's all one what's
up Chris this is at the parks up Chris
um so I was in coping
eating with Rene Redzepi and his family
at Sanchez which is Rocio Sanchez's
Mexican restaurants when the best
Mexican food in the world is in
Copenhagen because of Rocio and Rene his
family offing at Sunday brunch there and
I was visiting to visit the new Noma
with Toby my 13 year old then 12 but
some guy from a band I think was that
band st. Paul and the broken bone sort
of like one of these kind of neo-soul
bands coming up he came over to the
table just like oh my god are you Rene
Redzepi I can't believe it he's like
we're touring we're playing tonight you
want tickets like he was up he was so
freaked out that he was seeing Rene hmm
you know and I was like that is
fascinating so what do you make of that
I think it's indicative where the
cultural energy went you know um there's
a lot of great music coming out I mean I
actually I'm a weirdo I still buy CDs um
I'm obsessed with Aldous Harding who's
she's the singer from New Zealand I will
just play her CD on sort of a loop for
days and I you know I know through my
daughter and I know through my own
willful experiments in finding newness
that that there's still great stuff
being made but I think it's difficult
after so many decades of pop music in
its form in its recorded form it's
difficult not to say yeah this is cool
it's just like pavement yeah yeah which
was just like The Velvet Underground or
like this is a lot like the Pixies or
yeah this is cool it reminds me quite a
bit of Erykah Badu or you know like
you're after absorbing decades of
musical information it's hard sometimes
to confront originality to Stan locate
originality and I think with food even
though there are centuries of tradition
and culture informing it sometimes
things seem radically new and they bring
you that sort of receptivity and
excitement that you used to feel with
music I mean that's what happened to me
the first time in a Noma was I was
adrift and sad depressed and I was
at the point where I'd drive around play
rolling still play Exile on Main Street
that always used to work Loving Cup
always used to work I mean you talk
about self-medication Loving Cup always
did the trick and it wouldn't I can get
nothing out everything it just didn't
lift me it didn't rouse me it didn't
transform me and I was getting worried I
was like I'm so down that music does
nothing for me
you know Cat Power the greatest that
album is so morning to me and they would
just made me
disengage I was like I don't know what's
happening and for some reason went out
when I went to Nomo it was like oh my
god this is like seeing the clash when I
was 14 like I'm completely alive to this
I admit the guy recently who you should
have on the show I think of you probably
in a long time it's really annoying
Diego Zambrano he's from working company
he's one of the he's one of the most
influential designers in the world and
he's from Brazil originally but he now
lives in Brooklyn I met this guy at a
dinner and I didn't know who he was so I
was just talking to him and he's a cool
guy he told me that he this is very much
in in line with what you explore and on
the cast but he went to Noma Mexico he's
not a food guy or anything he's a
designer reason you know from that that
I think they designed Apple stores so
uh-huh that's pretty big
yeah that's yeah so that's a good one um
but uh he went to Noma Mexico and it
changed his life in every way it changed
his approach to creativity it changed
his approach to eating he's lost like 60
pounds he changed his whole diet he has
now been to Noma
seven times in Copenhagen he has almost
like a standing table there and he was
like he didn't know me I said well
you're gonna like my book you know yeah
he's like what's your book and I said my
books called hungry it's all about Rene
birds up and he's like oh i pre-ordered
that but um he feels that Rene Redzepi
is one of the great artists alive yeah
so the answer long-winded Li your
question that's the thing is we're
confronting people like Massimo Bottura
and Dominique Crenn and Rene Redzepi
Voorhis Leo Martinez and Peru who are
artists that's a controversial thing and
some people say that's bogus that they
just cooking
okay you go to Noma and you tell me
that's not all I love that I mean that's
that's it man the idea that this person
who is fully expressed in their
creativity can go to have a have an
experience at a restaurant that is so
impactful that it changes how they see
the world change sounds execs Travie
can't lie I don't think that possibly be
the case he showed me pictures he
started working out and stuff he showed
me pictures he was he was obese I mean
he he'd like Lhasa wow I was like we
have to do a panel together because the
fact that no much Ange your life in this
this way that lace is transformative
lightning-rod moment it's kind of what
I'm talking about - and it's hard to
convey the difficulty like a challenge
with his book for instance is like if I
was talking about record or ban that
changed my life
you'd go listen to him talking about a
film you'd go watch the film right and
that everyone can just hop on a plane
and go to nomás yeah and this is the
thing like where you know let's just
check our you know white male privilege
at the shore right now we're talking
about a restaurant that is in Copenhagen
that's impossible to get into and even
when you can is gonna cost you a fortune
yeah it's right and and so you know
let's just kind of walk through that you
know elitist land mine for a minute
because I think that's always when you
when you I think what I'm getting in a
restroom you can do well yeah the
elitist land line instead no well let's
take a bathroom but I don't actually Joe
again because the reason that my
intention behind this is that when you
when you fully understand who that who
Reds up he is you have a very different
yes you have a very different concept a
different lens on this whole thing than
what I originally projected onto it was
which was like oh this you know some
fancy chef and it's like this is
inaccessible you know how can i how can
i make this conversation around fancy
food relatable to the average person
yeah that's a very good question
I think that's probably my main obstacle
that to get over here because I I don't
actually think you have to be that
interested in food or high-end tasting
menu dining
to like this book but to get you to pick
it up I have to persuade you of that and
it's important to know that Renee's own
story is an immigrant story his father
was a Muslim
Albania ethnically albanian guy who grew
up was in Macedonia as part of the
Albanian diaspora so he came to
Copenhagen at a certain point in his
life you know for a better life and met
a Danish woman got married had Rene and
Kenneth who's his uh twin brother and
Rene grew up having the Koran read to
him as his bedside reading you know and
he grew up encountering a lot of bigotry
and being seen as an outsider dealing
with basically a lot of flat-out racism
toward his family and toward himself
it's you know and a name that's quite
unusual in in Denmark and a lot of
people don't know this about Rene they
assume these are just these fancy-pants
Vikings
you know and if you go to the Noma
kitchen which I'd love you to do someday
it's a fascinating experience because
you go in there and it's like it's a
small world at Disney I mean there's
people from all over the world there's
people from every continent men and
women of all different backgrounds it's
really not a Scandinavian restaurant at
all it's actually a global kitchen and
all the all those perspectives are
brought to bear on the cooking so you
know he's he's seen as The Godfather the
New Nordic movement but as I say in the
book it's really more about new as
opposed to Nordic he was sort of like
what if we hit reset what if we just
table you la raza the whole thing we get
rid of traditional Danish cooking and
think about what the landscape produces
what does it generate herbs vegetables
seafood etc what can we create that's a
kind of a new manifestation of the
spirit of this region so he's also you
know highly it's a highly democratic
Enterprise like I know this sounds crazy
when it's very expensive but they're
there tables set aside for students that
are offered at a discount all the time
like that's a regular I think every
single
night you know there are students who
can get a much cheaper rate and eat
there and it's not the white tablecloth
you know root you know prime rib car the
candelabras like vlog right it's not
that at all it's it feels very different
than that it's not like a restaurant
here's how I was saying to some somebody
and I think it's a generational shift
there are some of the older Chefs very
talented individuals whom I do believe
at the heart of it we're cooking for
rich people I mean that's that's what
the restaurant was about was it is
basically an enterprise to provide
luxury to wealthy patrons okay rich
people do indeed eat at Noma as they eat
at Blancas in Brooklyn and Momofuku Co
David Chang's place but those
enterprises were not built for rich
people they were built I really believe
this with a more democratic spirit and
they're meant to be accessible to anyone
you don't have to get dressed up there's
not all that kind of off-putting
formality and in haughtiness I get in
some trouble sometimes because I say
this to people but then for a kid who
grew up in San Marino in a way I have no
right to say it I could see that I grew
up you know pretty cozy but I don't care
how much a meal costs it actually
doesn't matter to me at all what matters
to me is if it's worth it and if it's
worth it it's just like tickets to
Hamilton you know I know people who
spend $800 on tickets to Hamilton they
couldn't afford it I couldn't afford it
either and then they went and it changed
their lot it was transformative and
they're like it's one of the great
memories of my life I believe that's
true about Noma III I think that that's
why I went into credit card debt and
start spending money you you under wrote
all these adventures going to Norway the
last third of the book is paid for by
the book advance some other trips to
married on Oaxaca and Norway and stuff
but like a lot of the early trips Sydney
essentially I mean Lauren and I just
paid for that on our own we bought our
own flights stayed at a the old Claire
hotel spent too much but
when you get the rush the contact I of
that that clarity that sense of mission
of eating at Noma or or other
restaurants like a name that are like
that you realize it's worth it okay it's
not by the way it's not like a thousand
dollars a person I don't actually know
what the current price is I have to
figure out how because I'm going to but
um it's I think like or do our vacations
worth it
you like the Rolling Stones our toilets
look what it is is the difference
between somebody who values experience
over material accumulation like where
where you prioritize what to do with
whatever disposable income you have some
people have a lot of that some people
have a little of that or not much of all
you know much of it at all but are you
thinking about like you know upgrading
your car or are you thinking about like
some experience that you're gonna go on
or take your family on or something that
will enrich you in a different way
that's ephemeral bingo so to me
experience is what's worth the money if
it delivers yeah I you would not eat
Journal a journeyman journalist if that
wasn't your priority that's what it's
that's what gets me high III don't even
buy new clothes as my wife would tell
you I don't even wash my clothes so I
apologize if I'm stinking up the studio
but III don't care about those luxury
things in any way I care about new
vantage points on life and that sense of
rush in your head that's like I'm really
alive right now that can come through a
poem for me it can come through a song
it can't come through time with my
children mmm it's true for so many of us
it could come for a long walk I love a
good walk you know and and those things
are free I just happen to Jeep to buy a
book of poetry or whatever but I feel
that Noma is worth it I'm not and I know
this I sound like an advertisement for
him and that's not what I wanted you
know Pete Wells it's a good friend of
mine at the New York Times is their
critic he makes fun of me because he
said that I sound like Dennis Hopper in
Apocalypse Now because this yeah Dennis
Hopper like lives up River where where
Marlon Brando's character look and he's
like
you gotta meet the man he's a god you
don't understand man he's a god
you got taste of you you've drunk the
guy no my believe it and there's some
truth to that I did get a little over
amped shall we say but I wouldn't say if
I didn't believe it so but what do you
extract from the experience that is
something that someone who's listening
to this who might never have the
opportunity to go to Noma can kind of
you know take home and incorporate into
their own life like what about you know
his philosophy on food or life and that
you find so infectious and and so you
know effervescent and invigorating you
know what can we bottle and and
repurpose for ourselves if life is not
working out for you change it that's not
a brand new statement we hear that from
Silicon Valley entrepreneurs and we hear
that from spiritual figures but there's
truth to it you know it may be your
relationship may be your line of work
it may be your health as you know change
it do that do the work say yes to that
that's that was really what Rene shook
me up yeah the [ __ ] is about saying yes
it's and it is about that's courage of
you know challenging whatever status quo
or rut that you find yourself in totally
get out of the rut like do the work to
to say to say yes today and I and and
also can I say something's very
interesting I talked about in the book
that when I first got a seat at Noma I
got a table for two and I had that all
these friends when they knew that I'd
met Renee and wrote about him in Mexico
they were like okay listen to me dude
seriously I will move [ __ ] mountains
you never get a table at Noma text me I
will buy a ticket immediately it's like
you sure yes all of those people some of
with some of whom have unlimited
resources which I do not some people
with a lot of money that was like I got
a table at Noma join me no can't do it I
got I got a rake the leaves man I'm
supposed to get a haircut I'm not
kidding
people said [ __ ] like this I was like
listen you told me you'd move Mountain
it was really interesting to me how many
people for
absolutely sensible reasons do not say
yes to the greatest experiences in life
so uh and I I just think that I I could
not afford this it was I mean it looks
like I'm just I really couldn't do it
but I found that I needed to I needed to
say yes to it and I realized it's an
extraordinary set of circumstances that
I happened to meet RNA and everything
but I do think that these opportunities
come about all the time and it could be
group of old friends from college group
of swimmers from the team we want to
finally get together you know I mean
this true me friends of mine are dying I
mean oh yeah you know starting to lose
people in my life or they're getting
sick it's like let's get together let's
go for a hike let's have a weekend
together say yes to that you know I'm
not I'm not trying to make some snotty
argument like everyone should eat in
Denmark I mean it's it's it's about like
you are here now make the most of it and
change what's not working you know that
for your from your own life you know you
had to make that change
and I think it's crucial like I'm a much
happier person now yeah um it I think
that's right I think that's a powerful
lesson you know for everybody and it's
something I'm trying to do better at
like I had that very example has come up
like old swimmer friend of mine called
me up hey I want to get everyone back
together I want to go on a little trip
yeah and I immediately go to all the
reasons why I can't do it and I'm like
this is never gonna happen again
I have to find a way to say yes to this
and that's an immoral but I think all of
us every day not every day but
periodically throughout our lives are
visited with little tiny little
opportunities to say yes do that we just
don't because it's so easy to just
default to you know whatever has to get
done the next week I mean I started this
week in Santa Barbara I landed in
Burbank I'm a big proponent of the
Burbank and Long Beach Airport says I'm
an airport where it's at that's
Californians exactly live in 1950 you
know pulled right up to the door strat
like one b-team better man it's like
it's so um that I drove straight up to
Santa Barbara one of my closest friends
took his own life there a few weeks ago
I saw your Instagram yeah
and I didn't make it to the more
memorial service for the same reasons
we're talking about but I mean I
absolutely bonafide excuses for children
all in my care deadlines prior I mean it
just couldn't happen unfortunately but I
knew I wanted to go back at least
privately and pay my respects
true story weird thing soon as I was
going into Santa Barbara Elton John's
funeral for a friend was playing on the
radio is that weird
Wow yes we're um but I just found that
even taking this time in a context that
is otherwise useless it certainly can't
be monetized there's no payoff but just
going to Santa Barbara standing on the
beach thinking of Russ I'm a dork so I
read a few poems out loud I just sort of
sent up thoughts to him it was worth it
you know is worth saying yes to that it
yeah if you went on Instagram looked
like I was just getting a burger and a
martini which I did do as well but I you
know I really actually got from the
Santa Barbara independent terrific
alternative weekly up there wanted to
write about the book so I said to him
you know oh oh come on up yeah he was
like wait you're coming to Santa Barbara
like yeah but really it was to pay
tribute to Russ so um but you know that
moment happened he had a lot of demons
yeah he was struggling with mental
illness and a surfer filmmaker yeah I
mean an extraordinary filmmaker he's a
great writer surfed almost every morning
he seemed like you know what these
people have on the surface seem to have
the perfect life you know and and he
made a beautiful film about a local
barbershop
he made a beautiful film about a
one-point something he Anna Wright yeah
man you do your work it's like they put
pianos out on State Street just so
people could play them at random and he
made this this very tone poem like film
just capturing people playing the pianos
in the middle of the night some of them
drunk some of them in love some old
people some of them super you know
little kids it was just the most
beautiful thing
he had so much spirit but he had a lot
of you know you'd get these crazy calls
it was like it was like them the movie
beautiful mind you know is like he would
see things and hear voices and think
that the government was after him and
stuff and those of us who were close to
me didn't know how to fix that I mean
you didn't there's it's very difficult
to it's like people like that whose
light shines bright but it's not meant
long for the world
yeah I don't know like I mean if you
have friends I mean I saw a friend just
recently he was really struggling with
depression stuff I you know take the
time meet talk maybe read this
call me Anita there's things you can say
with other kinds of mental illness is
very difficult it's it's it's so
distressing and so confusing that at
times Russ seemed very stable and normal
mmm in fact the last time I saw him in
person he he said man everything's good
I'm in a good place you know but then it
would come back I don't know why I'm
sorry I'm babbling down this track but
it but it's as I get older I'm realizing
that some of these people I love you
know they're not going to be with us
forever obviously and I need to start
saying yes to these moments even when it
means putting work aside and spending
money that I don't have and and that
that that's the essence of life you know
and you get as a writer you need that's
it's imperative that you live your life
and embrace the world otherwise you
don't have you know a tableau to write
from experiences the juice from the you
know Mitch's which everything else
Springs and you know part of this
conversation sort of been like a walk
down gen-x memory lane yeah and you
wrote a book about Jenna
I did I came out like ten years ago
so I'm interested in like like your
thoughts on like like how do you feel
about Gen X now versus how you felt
about when you wrote that book you know
the New York Times did this big Gen X
package recently announced will
who wrote one of the pieces of it kindly
approach gen-x will save us is it there
was no thing this up by some big package
and you know he said do you want to talk
you know just can I interview you and I
did the dumbest thing that an author can
do I declined the telling you to say yes
I didn't say yes I was like you know
I've really left that Gen X thing right
I felt very liberated by no in this
particular case I said I really
appreciate you approaching me and he did
actually mention the book and in the
piece but I was like you know I don't
wanna get down that Lane anymore I don't
know all that demographic stuff just
seemed kind of meaningless after a while
there's a point at which you keep
talking about a book so much that it
almost dislodges from reality and you're
not even sure like this I've been very
honest and this is a nice way of talking
but sometimes I feel like I just go into
autopilot and and some of the Gen X
points I I have nothing left to say I
don't mean that as some snobby way I
just I just I just didn't even want to
contribute to it and I will tell you
this if you ever have a temptation to
write some sort of Gen X manifesto don't
don't
it's totally bombed dude it totally bug
ya here's here's the thing like I mean
Nick Hornby like did a couple people I
wrote about in the believe it there was
something that's cool you'll always have
that seriously that's my takeaway
it's like Nick Hornby Doug rushkoff I
got to be friends with some some really
great authors and thinkers who did like
the book somehow book was written really
quickly like for months
anyway and people say it's not really
thought through it doesn't it's kind of
ramshackle and I was like you're
absolutely correct
anything written that quickly but
boomers baby boomers they love to read
about boomers if Tom Brokaw is doing
another special about baby boomers on TV
guess what my in-laws are gonna watch
the boomers show Millennials they just
want to talk about being a millennial
all the time Gen Xers rather read a book
about some obscure snail in TASMAC
Tasmania or said like it's like we are
so ornery and contrarian and again
that's a crazy generalization of course
but I have sensed it so
often people our age I just sense it
like conversation goes into the most
obscure bands and films and cultural
moments that we share that are cherished
in part because of their distance from
the mainstream you know that's exactly
what we love about it so the last thing
Gen Xers want to do is read a book about
Generation X they actually have they
don't have any interest I tried believe
me so um let's keep our are our secret
little fetishes in the dark yeah our
little group as as Kurt Cobain said like
you know every now and then somebody
would be like I liked your book I liked
the Mission of Burma reference and I'll
be like oh you got the mission number no
reference okay this is a good day like
my work is done
speaking of references like you are you
just you did Brian compliments podcast
right yeah I'm sure do you watch
billions yeah we're so I'm obsessed with
Taylor and I'm obsessed with wags it's
so good
right those characters to me I mean the
writing of the characters it's
incredible yeah
and Brian also being our age is like the
king of dropping obscure Gen X you know
references throughout that show like the
more obscure the better yeah and I don't
even I don't get all of them you know
but everyone's wrong like oh yeah well
you know he has the reason I got to know
Brian is because I wrote a thing for
Esquires website about how billions was
essentially the best food show on TV
uh-huh and huge foodie restaurants are
character in the show yeah he is very
intelligent about the place that these
restaurants occupy in the consciousness
of new you right so they are chosen very
smartly like suddenly Dave Chang appears
or suddenly Wylie Dufresne appears in
the order long scene and you think bingo
that was so well done like he he knows
it's character specific consistent yeah
it's a Koppelman knows that the cultural
conversation has shifted he knows where
wags woody and he knows where Chuck
woody for instance like and and those
are very different places they're very
different places and and like the the
may be one of the best food scenes of
all time
is when wags wigs out at sushi nakazawa
because of the like douche bro at the
end of the counter who's talking on his
phone and dunking everything offends a
soy sauce it's just that was sublime
piece of writing it's weird
and amazing how a restaurant can evoke
not just a specific memory but like a
setting and a time in a place like if
you say to me cafe Odeon or Balthazar or
Nels like these are all iconic you know
New York establishments or V McNally
please yeah exactly right they all
conjure up something very specific in my
mind as somebody who lived there during
you know various periods of time when
those things were important yeah it's
funny you say I just wrote a piece for
the issue previous to this one about
Pastis coming back besties yeah I was
one of the Keith McNally successes it
was really the his is uh the the the
follow-up to Baltazar and Meatpacking
District which at that time was still
pretty scuzzy gnarly the only hang there
was floral
yeah floral that's right and in the hogs
and heifers was nearby but it was like
very marginal neighborhood and Pastis
essentially catalyzed the gentrification
that forced it out eventually you know
became a victim of its own success
exactly and now the Meatpacking District
is like a tourist mall and they brought
pasties back and so I wrote a piece
about that and to the to what extent do
we need it back like we'll be the same
thing the neighborhood is different the
feelings gonna be different campy it
won't be it can't be and also in the
food world the conversation has very
much moved away from that sort of
Eurocentric white male dining we've
really moved toward you know so many
exciting restaurants that are about the
African Diaspora they're about you know
Mumbai in Oakland California was
Cambodian food yeah hi hi in Minneapolis
I Celeste day in Boston L Hardeen in San
Diego I couldn't get named hundreds of
places that are really where the
conversation has moved and probably
should have long ago long overdue
diversity in the conversation about
food in America and all these stories
Middle Eastern food etc and where does
pasties fit in that you know cuz we're
talking about a steak frites place
basically we're talking about a place
that is in itself a gesture of nostalgia
mm-hmm for a France that never even
existed and then so rebooting it is
nostalgia for the nostalgia for frames
right in New York and a time and a place
pre Instagram where it wasn't
necessarily about the food but it was
more of this meson sun and sea to be
seen and to see others and not right
there your phone you remember we need to
go to a bar at a restaurant and you
didn't have phones guess what you do you
talk to people you know you Domingo talk
to people flirt joke around argue a
little bit it's fun I mean I I I have
gotten to where lately this has nothing
to do with our conversation but I just I
just lately have thought I want to get a
giant fly swatter like a really big
cartoonish fly swatter foam-like don't
hurt anybody and I just want to walk
down the streets of New York and swap he
phones that off out of people's hands
because there's times you're going down
Broadway or Fifth Avenue 7,000 you can't
believe it
it just looks like an ant farm
everybody's got their heads down and
they're actually banging into each other
I mean can it wait I mean this isn't
even a new fresh observation but but
lately it seems so overwhelming that
four miles four miles you don't see a
single person not on his or her phone
mmm like we're doomed we're doomed if
that like right now try to no I don't
know what it's gonna be and part of that
is like you know the old man howling at
the moon maybe all of us but I wonder
also like where is the relevance of New
York City now versa I mean it doesn't it
doesn't feel like it did in the 80s and
the 70s the early 90s and now we have a
we are 15 year-old daughter goes to high
school downtown which is like a two-hour
drive from here so we write at a loft in
downtown in the arts district in
downtown LA Wow and Julie and I split
the week stay
there so I live in the arts district
half the week I didn't know that and I'm
feeling like a sense of energy and
urgency and vitality and vibrancy in
that little neighborhood that reminds me
of you know when I was 21 and living in
New York like there's something
happening down there and I think it's
happening not just with art but with
food I saw it from your Instagram you it
looks like you were down there yeah
there's really tacos oh yeah there's
some grit we are places literally across
the street from girl talking oh yeah I
mean guerrilla tacos is its goal
transformed yeah there's a lot of really
interesting things happening down there
absolutely I see I see like the
epicenter of a lot of these you know
kind of the cultural Genesis happening
out of little pockets like this I feel
like there will never be another band
like Sonic Youth out of New York City
there will never be another Velvet
Underground out of New York City forget
it it's over yeah I mean The Strokes
were maybe so where is that happening
it's where is that moment Denver down
right maybe Detroit I was just in
Detroit is crazy so if I was like an
artist in 20 years old right now moved
to Detroit yeah I mean and you know my
friend Davina Davison runs a food lab
Detroit in in that city and she is very
active in making sure that a sort of
sweeping gentrification doesn't change
the character of the city too much and
doesn't take away ownership and
influence and voices from black owners
Mexican owners like I mean she's there
to foster business business building and
creativity and entrepreneurship for
people who live there who part of the
communities and it's a beautiful thing
to see
I think she's she deserves a prize you
know and because the dangerous aspect of
these cities having a kind of hipster
infusion you know is that the character
the city is drained away and and and the
fortitude of the people who live there
you know doesn't always go recognized
you know and so
what I loved about my trip to Detroit
recently is that it seems Detroit driven
a lot of what I saw is local people
expressing themselves through food
through music I'm babbling but I think I
think that it's very simple why some of
these cities are vortices of dynamism
creatively right now you can afford to
live there and you can afford to be
creative I went to Dallas for Esquire
magazine and you know people see on the
Instagram you've landed I post some from
the airport and they start bombarding me
with recommendations and a lot of people
said you got to go to Petra Petra yeah
you know this I know I've heard of this
place
yeah okay so so some somebody I don't
know who was somebody on Instagram said
you got to go to Petra the Beast no
seriously didn't make time for this I
googled it it looked really interesting
so I made the trip I was the only
customer I had like three in the
afternoon misty Norris is the chef there
which was misty and a guy now it's the
whole kitchen I basically ordered the
whole menu which is usually a towel yeah
I know who you were probably I mean I
don't I I eventually usually just
introduce myself after I've gotten going
or you know I don't I don't use a fake
name or anything so because my role is
not that of like an anonymous critic and
also I do a lot of reporting with these
folks I interviewed them too so you know
after a while and also I like to do
pictures and it looks weird if you don't
explain the context it looks creepy
so this food was revolutionary it was
you really sensed a voice and a vision
the restaurant was built in like a
converted gas station looks like
something from Grapes of Wrath she's
cranking music she's got like anime and
cow skulls and all these things on the
walls like her own decor and but the
food was vivid and funky with fermented
flavors and lots of things she doesn't
have kind of Francis mall minish way
with fire
I had never tasted anything like it I
thought that it was like hearing cat
power for the first time
I don't know some a band and NWA
somebody will you hear it you like I've
never heard anything like this this is a
vital new voice and so I included Petra
in the Beast and best new restaurants
but I also fell to answer your question
sorry I'm long-winded but petram the
beats could not happen in New York City
at this point it would not survive she
her rent would be extortion it's in she
converted like a gas station right yeah
it means she couldn't have this space I
went to uh Oh Tony Oh a Spanish
restaurant in Highland Park last night
loved it and Theresa the chef introduced
herself when I was leaving and I said
you know in this in New York City this
space would be like three million
dollars a month right it's gigantic and
got beautiful high ceilings beautiful
kind of murals on the walls even here in
Los Angeles obviously a major American
city I don't think you could do what
Otto neo does in New York um the economy
has become untenable in New York for a
lot of creative people there are still
excellent restaurants they're still art
happening but it doesn't have that
scuzzy vitality yeah you know that it
you just required that like tension to
create something great and I mean we
have the Talking Heads Patti Smith The
Ramones I mean CBGB's couldn't happen
and none of those people could afford to
live in New York you couldn't live in
New York no no and I mean you know so
that's actually an exciting element of
my job at Esquire is going to all these
cities because I feel that creative
energy I really felt it in Minneapolis
Philadelphia a lot happened in there
creativity will happen it's it's like it
will out no matter what you know it is
powerful and all the corporate forces of
gentrification will try as they might
but we will always find other places to
pop out and make things yeah so yeah
it's interesting I mean you like this
has been an amazing conversation and
there's so much more going on here than
food like you're almost like a Chuck
Klosterman type person oh I like like
yeah I mean you have a see me but I
but like but like you have it you have
it you have a take in a perspective on
like culture you know that yeah it's
much more than just you know food or I
ate at this restaurant yeah I mean I
started as a political writer years ago
then for most of my career as a music
writer then I was music and film then I
was at details writing about guys you
know who fix broken sex dolls and stuff
yeah then I was a food writer at the New
York Times for six years and now I'm
seen as a food writer but but I actually
don't think of myself as a food writer I
just think is myself as somebody
interest in people yeah and and I could
absolutely change gears any minute now
I have done it many times much the
consternation of people in my life and
you know the last lines of this book are
it can change it can change you can
change and that is on my mind partly
because I'm concerned about health but
also I found myself drawn to other
subjects more and more so we'll see III
don't actually drink much for instance
like I do write about drinks as well and
I I definitely save her a martini a good
natural wine whatever but I'm not I'm
not like I've never been a big Boozer
you know so like that element like we
discussed of indulgence and a kind of
obliteration doesn't appeal to me well
now that you live here at our house yeah
and that's out of the TP yes are you
yeah but I put my back you set it up for
you all right man I can let you go but
final question okay um where's the best
burrito in LA oh my gosh or at least a
burrito that I can veganize I I think
you've stumped me cuz I know that's
crazy I tend to be a taco right well
ever I mean uh taco is tacos I'm more of
a burrito guy real talk see the thing
okay I'll tell you I'm a corn tortilla
guy oh yeah I'm a flower oh yeah this is
it we can't make this the last question
just a terrible note to know that you're
a flower towards you guys I said corn
tortillas are the spirit of Mexico now I
don't I'm not one of those authenticity
fetishists i'm with gustavo Ariano on
this i mean to me a flour tortilla
he's a great writer for the LA Times and
stuff and he he's a brilliant dude he
wrote a whole book of called taco USA
and he argues against that enshrinement
of certain things as authentic Mexican
food and other things is not and he says
like tex-mex and burritos or San Diego
fish tacos things that are a little bit
of a hybrid and a little bit of a
appropriation even are as authentic and
expression of Mexican cuisine as
anything else okay I appreciate that
that said the kind of your
traditionalist
I like the chew of a corn tortilla
I like that like particularly when it's
a really well made one so I mean I went
to gorilla tacos yesterday was my friend
Franz and we ordered prolly 10 tacos
like 10 different types and I guess I
didn't I had a breakfast burrito this
morning I will tell you but that's
that's all I'm gonna say about it I
wasn't that into it but uh God let's see
you know there was a I'm feelin so on
I'm looking for like don't kind of hole
in the wall it's all about the mission
it's in San Francisco I know that in San
Francisco them that's the other thing
like a leather massive yeah but I don't
need them to be massive I like them to
have that sear from the grill so they
fold it all in and then crisp it up on
the grill and have all the things melt
and merge inside that's what makes it
work so it's sometimes just about
technique I also like like pannu shows
and soap bays and like all the different
kind of forms of tortillas and stuff
like that but oh man
I guess I'll there was a place in like
Rosemead California this is typical of
my high school years that we found some
really great burrito place that was just
far enough away that we could get there
during our lunch break at school order a
burrito and race back and make it a
class in like a minute and we would do
it because these burritos were so good
and I cannot remember the name of the
place wow that's embarrassing on you I
know it's really embarrassing I mean it
was like 16 years old but my best buddy
in high school rich became a chef for a
while he was
Jeff in Paris and in London I'm not
lettin excuse me in Los Angeles under
why I said London and Pasadena and he
eventually it's hard being a chef hard
working at high and everything he
eventually went to business school and
worked at williams-sonoma but we were
really into food I mean we were like the
proto footings as teenagers we didn't
call it that up so you know what it was
it's we its inch so interesting that you
had that and you kind of moved away from
that and be on your way back to it yeah
I'd loved restaurants when I was a kid
though because it you know some kids are
like theater geeks they love theater
they're just entranced by it you know
which is a beautiful thing for me
restaurants were like theater I would
love like I remember the Mandarin in San
Francisco Cecilia Chang Chinese
restaurant my parents would we'd go up
to San Francisco from LA and just almost
explicitly to go there like my family
was really into Chinese food still is
and um you know Spago I mean you know at
certain point my dad was doing pretty
well never never go in the original
Spago and just think he was magic and
not because of celebrities stuff but
because of this it was up on the hill
and it was just the most to me it was
just sexy and elegant yeah um I've kind
of an addiction to that and it's all
different types of restaurants
I mean escolar best new restaurants that
included a carnitas place in San Antonio
where you can get out of there for 10
bucks the other places are really fancy
to me it's just like how does it make
you feel when you walk in which is me
dodging the burrito I know I still like
that answer
I know but no place to go for my burrito
so embarrassed
Jonathan Gloria would would his mom
you're gonna think about it and then I'm
gonna put it in the show notes yeah I'll
think about it
just we saw this have burritos see I
always get tacos there but anyway you
wouldn't go there cuz that's yeah now
meets it sorry yeah I mean I'll go to
life
I like holy guacamole on Main Street oh
yeah dives but I think the food there's
great yeah you know I like little places
like that yeah and actually tray hose
tacos is not bad oh yeah that's pretty
good
do they have some vegetable options yeah
they have like a jackfruit taco you can
get there and Giles riverita I'm gonna
go check for ya I really am
I've become a convert I made it vegan
jackfruit bibbing Bop from I know
nothing about sports who's that who's
the quarterback of the Patriots say Tom
Brady yeah wow you really know I really
don't know I know like LeBron James
AHA and Tiger Woods and then like nobody
so like um Tom Brady had have had a meal
kit where I still have it that's vegan
yeah with um purple carrot perhaps like
yeah there's caramel Delaney and I did a
Esquire article on meal kits and they
and and they got this bib in pop one
with jackfruit you had to roast the
jackfruit uh-huh dude it was so good
right
it was great nice I mean I hate anything
from Boston so I don't want to flat
celebrate this but but I must say it was
a very delicious Pippin Bob and I felt
very good
so anyway shout out to purple carrot uh
I can't I'm Andy I what's gonna end on
this burrito I don't know and now I'm
ending on a Tom Brady reference what's
happening I don't know we better end it
now all right man we got I gotta let you
go oh come thanks for house great that
was super fun no I really enjoyed it I
feel good oh yeah yeah just take out all
the dumb things I said no we're not
editing any of this [ __ ]
the book is hungry chefs easy to find on
the internet too easy
Instagram and I mean you can do you can
just go down the rabbit hole on you can
find all the articles he's written on
the New York Times at Esquire all that a
lot of I know there's a lot of stuff in
your garage but there's a lot of stuff
online - yeah check them out enjoy it
and pick up the book man I'm diggin it
thanks rich thanks a lot all right for
the time come back we talk to me again
okay tomorrow since I hated feasts
[Music]